Oh my god.
This game.
I also need to remember not to swear.
The first 10 minutes.
Oh my god.
Just so you guys know, if you don't follow me on Twitter, My bunny garden video, it got hit.
It 100% got hit.
And then I had to peel it.
And then they got it.
And then they...
And then they like... It's monetizable again.
It was limited.
And then I was like, no.
I swear.
This is advertiser friendly.
Please.
Please review my stream.
I swear.
I honestly thought it was a good stream.
I thought they were not going to appeal it.
Because they were going to rewatch the stream.
And they were going to be like, oh wait.
We made the right decision.
Because of the actual contents of the stream.
But then I peeled it.
And then a couple of hours later, they were like, yep.
You're right.
It is advertiser friendly.
I was like, yay.
Nice to know that profanity is where they draw the line.
It's nice to know that.
Not anything else in the stream.
But the profanity is where we draw the line.
John, you found a box full of caps.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Anyway.
Okay, let me... Okay.
This game.
Okay.
So I was googling the problems.
I know.
I like how some of you guys are like, Doki, don't you test games before your stream?
Look.
Usually, yes.
But when it's... When it's a stream that's at 1230, no.
Any stream that is like at 1230, that is like, you know, I would usually be awake at 1220.
I would usually be awake at 1220.
So you would expect me not to test anything by then.
.
No stream at 12... No game at 1230 is gonna get tested before stream.
We do it live.
We like pray that like everything will be okay.
And there will be no troubles, no issues whatsoever.
But every time... Every time I'm always hopeful that today would be different.
Today was not different.
.
One day.
One day!
I... Okay.
To be fair, it's only if it's like not like... If it's a game that I've never played before.
But one day, a game that I've never played before is going to run perfectly at 1230.
One day!
Okay.
Anyway, here is another issue that I ran into.
So...
So I was freaking out in chat because I was like...
I booted up the game and it was a black screen.
Which just like... I hear the music and everything.
And I was like, wait, what?
What's going on?
And then... So like I was freaking out because I was like, oh no, not another technical.
Why is it always 1230 when we have technical issues?
Why is every game I play at 1230 we encounter something?
And then so I googled it and it's so weird.
It's like... Apparently it's a really common issue.
Thank you, Todd.
We love your games.
You don't understand, guys.
Sorry, not an issue.
An experience.
According to Mr. Todd Howard himself.
Every bug and glitch is an experience.
Into the world of Bethesda games.
Anyway, so I googled it and then it was like...
Oh, you have to go to the documents?
And then you have to go to my games?
And then you have to go to Fallout 76?
And you have to click the Fallout preference?
And then you have to go look at this exact game feature in the preference in the notepad?
And you have to put it at zero?
So I was like, oh, okay.
I did all that and I edited the document, the notepad document, and I put it at zero.
Put it up.
It's great.
And then suddenly...
And then suddenly it was like...
Oh.
You gotta create a Bethesda account.
And I was like, okay.
So then I was like, okay, type in your email and your username.
I was like, okay.
And then I looked at the bottom.
AYX.
I was like, wait.
Not okay.
So...
So I was like, wait.
Why is it controller button?
And then...
I plugged in my controller.
And I was like, okay.
A.
Put it to work.
I was like, huh?
Wait.
What do you mean?
And I was like, okay.
A.
I was like, oh no.
So...
I had to Google that as well.
I was like, controller.
Forced controller on Fallout 76.
And then they're like, oh yeah.
You have to go to...
You have to go to my documents.
And then my game in Fallout 76.
And then change controller to zero.
So like, as in like, not forced controller.
I was like, oh.
Okay.
But then like...
But then the thing is...
The thing is...
Before all that...
I was like, try to like, make my own solution.
Like force...
I just brute force my own solution.
Because you can disable controller input on Steam.
So I did that.
And I disabled controller input on Steam.
And everything.
And I was like, does this work?
And then I looked below.
A, Y, Z... oh wait not A, Y, Z.
A, Y, X.
I was like, oh...
I just... guys, I'm having a great time with Fallout 76 already.
I'm already modding the game before we even played the game.
I already have to like mod the game just to force myself to be able to play the game.
Also, by the way, I went to bed at like...
Okay guys.
There was another reason why I was EP.
I have a problem.
Before I tell you guys what I mean by I have a problem.
Please don't judge me.
Guys, okay.
If you guys promise me you won't judge me.
I will tell you the reason why I have a problem.
But... but...
I have to make sure that people say I'll never judge you Doki because you're perfect.
And anything that I say.
Anything that seems unperfect.
Is just...
Is just a lie.
You're perfect, my queen.
I need someone to type exactly what I said.
There.
And then I'll tell you the story.
I need at least one person to type it fully.
Wow!
I'll never judge you because you're perfect, my queen.
Oh my god.
Look at all these very natural responses.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
I can't believe all of you guys would say something very similar.
All at once.
Oh my...
I'll never judge you, my queen.
What does LIE mean?
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay.
Guys.
So the reason why is that I went to bed at like 7 a.m.
And I was like, I'm going to bed.
Because I was playing Overwatch rank.
Okay.
Look.
I have...
Guys.
Look.
I have a perfect, reasonable explanation.
Chat.
I haven't touched Overwatch 2 rank like actually seriously for a while now.
Then there are moments when you're playing a competitive multiplayer FPS games.
And then you hit that moment.
You hit...
You hit that moment where you couldn't stop playing.
And unfortunately, I was like messing about on like Overwatch 2 rank.
And then I hit that moment.
Because like I was doing...
I was doing like placements.
And then like I got like D1.
And then I was like I want to be masters on this account.
And then I hit that moment.
And then I played...
I played...
Played for like...
The most fucked up part was I was doing late night queues.
That was like the most fucked up part.
Because late night queues are the worst that you never climb on.
But then I was like I'm different.
I was like no.
I'm different.
There's no...
Late night queues are nothing to me.
I'll be different.
I'm different.
So.
So the thing is...
The thing is...
I hit...
I hit masters.
But another thing is...
Another thing is...
You don't stop when you're on a streak.
But then...
The thing is...
And now, after 5 plus hours of playing, I am not masters anymore.
And then... so, this is how it goes usually.
You're like, oh I'm gonna get it.
You get it and you're like, I don't wanna end the streak because I'm lucky right now.
And then you start losing.
And then you're like, I'm not gonna end on a loss.
And then you keep losing.
And then you're like, I'm not gonna end on a loss streak.
And then you win a game.
And then you're like, oh...
This is where I hit my win streak.
I might as well keep going.
Because I might be able to get back my masters.
And then you still keep losing.
And then you're like, well, obviously I can't end on a loss.
Okay, to be fair...
I would have been okay...
If it wasn't for one game that boosted my ego so fucking hard.
Like... I had one game where my ego got boosted so fucking hard...
That I was like, I'm gonna keep going.
Because obviously I'm a fucking insane player.
That I deserve to be top 500.
And...
I don't know.
I'm into cap.
Johnathan Perry.
Thank you.
Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Look!
I blame Bunny Gaiden.
It triggered something inside of me.
I blame...
But the thing is...
During the moment in those late night queues...
There was a moment where I acce- I don't know how...
But I got into a game...
The rank-range was...
Diamond one?
1 to GM... Grandmaster 2.
And then everyone in my lobby was like, what the fuck?
Like, what is this range?
And like, who is the Diamond 1 player?
I was the Diamond 1 player.
I didn't say anything because I didn't want people to yell at me if we lose.
But people in the game were like, who the fuck is the Diamond player?
In this lobby.
Because that lobby...
I was actually the only Diamond 1 player.
I was the only Diamond player in that lobby.
But the thing was...
That lobby was filled with actual Overwatch League players.
At late night queues, by the way.
At late night queues.
There was like Overwatch League players on the enemy team.
And then my team had like 1 or 2 players.
And then I had like 1 or 2 players from the ex-rank 1 DPS player on my team.
Like the person who used to be rank 1 DPS player.
And then I was like, oh no.
Oh no.
So the thing was...
The thing was...
At the end of the game...
People were like...
One of my teammates was calling out the enemy Ana's player.
The enemy Ana player.
And was like, are you the Diamond player, Ana?
And then the Ana player on the enemy team was like...
No I'm Master 4.
And then I was like...
Because we were winning.
Because we were winning...
I was like...
I'm the Diamond 1 player.
And so they were like...
And then my teammates were like...
Wait, no serious?
No shit?
I was like...
I didn't use my voice because I was also scared they were going to be like women.
But all of a sudden I was like...
I was like...
Yeah...
I'm serious.
And they were like...
Oh my god you're actually really good.
And then one person on my team was like...
You have been...
Who was like...
You're better than all the supports I've had today.
Like no lie.
I'm serious.
And then I was like...
And then he sent me a friend request.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Maybe I do deserve to be in top 5.
I was like...
I've been losing...
I have a very bad win-loss ratio right now.
But it is definitely my teammates.
And it is not me.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Now I know for sure.
It's not me.
It's my teammates.
I gotta keep going.
I gotta keep playing.
Cause now I know for sure it's not me.
I could have stopped so much earlier.
But that moment...
That moment I was like...
Oh my god.
I need to keep going.
Eventually I'll get the cash out.
Cause like...
It wasn't just that person.
Like multiple people on my team were like...
You're the diamond player?
Bro you don't deserve to be in that rank.
I was like... Oh my god.
Really?
And one guy was like...
You know like those people...
You know those people that were like...
I don't deserve to be in diamond.
I'm like clearly better than my rank.
That's actually you.
You could take this gameplay and make a video.
Where it was like... I deserve to be top 500.
And I was like... Me?
Hahahaha Hahahaha Like I was like...
You could take this video and actually like...
Make it into some fucking highlight.
To be like...
I deserve to be top 500.
I don't deserve to be in diamond.
And I'm serious.
And you're like one of those people that actually deserve that.
I was like... Oh my god.
Me?
Hahahaha
It was multiple.
It was like three different people were like...
Yeah you are not a diamond one player.
You're actually pretty good.
I'm like... Oh my god.
I'm actually pretty good.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Alright.
Yeah so...
So...
Ummm...
So that is why...
I had a problem last night.
I had a huge issue last night.
Because if it wasn't for those people...
For gassing me up.
I would have cashed out early.
No it's not me.
I was not the problem.
And I kept going.
But then at one point I was like...
Maybe...
And then at one...
No it was never my problem.
But thing is...
I realized late night queues was never like the answer.
It was never...
Never played late night queues.
Because...
Because it is definitely an issue.
And I feel like that was why I was losing.
Not because of me.
Obviously.
But it was never my problem.
But because late night queues was a huge problem.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Okay here.
Here look.
See you are like 10 times better than all my support players today.
Well played.
You are the GOAT.
That was my highlight.
Hahahaha And then...
The thing was...
I took a screenshot of fucking course.
I needed the ego boost guys.
Like...
I needed the ego boost.
I took more than just one screenshot.
There was more behind.
But like I am too embarrassed to show the other screenshots.
But to show the other screenshots they were saying.
Because...
But this one I took.
Anyway...
That was my highlight.
Okay not only did I take screenshots.
But there were streamers in my game as well.
But the thing is...
They put sub...
I wanted to clip that moment.
To be like whenever I feel down.
And wonder is it me.
I can look at that clip.
And be like it was not me.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha But the thing is...
The VODs.
All the streamers that were streaming that game.
The VODs were sub only mode.
And I was like.
Am I that desperate?
Am I that desperate to use my Twitch Prime.
On one of these streamers.
Just so I can like...
Clip that one moment.
And be like I still got it.
Hahahaha.
I was like...
Do I...
Bro I am not going to pay it.
I am not going to use actual money.
I was going to use my Twitch Prime.
Anyway you guys don't know what Twitch Prime is.
It's basically.
If you have Amazon Prime.
And you linked it on your Twitch account.
You can subscribe to your favorite streamer.
I.e.
me.
At Doki Bird at Twitch.
So why don't you throw your Twitch Prime at Doki Bird.
But yeah.
I was like no.
Don't use your Twitch Prime.
Just for that one game.
That one moment in your life.
When all these top 500 players.
Were like.
Wow.
You don't deserve to be in that elo.
You truly.
Hahahaha.
Because before then.
I was always.
I was like.
Do I actually deserve to be in Diamond?
Or anything.
Is it me?
But now I know.
It was never me.
So.
And that is why.
I slept at 7 in the morning today.
Because of that one fateful game.
That kept me going.
What I kept.
Fiction thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't do what I did.
And play competitive constantly.
To the point you make the lives of people around you living hell.
And punch a hole in your wall.
Holy fuck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I cried.
Because I lost top 500.
I think it was for Overwatch.
No.
It was for both Apex and Overwatch.
I cried because I had very unlucky games.
And I was so close to top 500.
But then I had some series of very unlucky games.
And I didn't destroy a mouse.
Not because of anger.
It's not because of anger.
That I destroyed a mouse.
It's because I was playing.
Okay.
For those who don't know the story.
At one point Mercy was meta.
And I really hated playing Mercy.
Because I was one of those players that tried to avoid Mercy.
Because the moment you play Mercy in a game.
And you open your voice.
People will be like.
Typical Mercy main.
So I made it my damn hardest.
To never play Mercy.
Because I was so mad.
Whenever people would be like.
Typical Mercy one trick.
So that I made.
My damn hardest.
To never pick that character.
But then Mercy became meta.
So I had no excuse.
Because it's like.
I think it was Mercy and Zenyatta.
Were most meta.
And I didn't really want to play Zenyatta.
Because at that time.
It was like hard dive.
And I was like.
I'm not playing Zenyatta.
In hard dive.
I was like.
That sounds fucking miserable.
So I played Mercy for the meta.
And so like.
Because of that.
I was gripping my mouse.
So fucking hard.
That like the left mouse button broke off.
And like.
And the side grips also.
Peeled off.
The side grip.
Because it's like the tape thing on the back.
Of the side grip.
And then the left mouse button.
Fucking snapped off.
And like I had a photo of it a long time ago.
I need to like dig it up.
But like yeah.
That was the first time I ever broke my mouse.
From playing Mercy.
It was the first and only time.
I've ever broke my mouse.
Anyway guys.
It's been 26 minutes.
And we still haven't played the game.
So...
So here we are.
Let's actually.
Did you?
I don't know guys.
It was like 6 plus years ago.
It was Overwatch 1.
But okay.
Game.
Wait what?
Tab.
Oh wait.
Oh I was like.
What?
Okay.
Play.
World found.
Alright we're actually gonna play the.
I can actually finally play the game.
Sorry for everybody that was waiting for a very long time.
So the reason why I'm playing.
Fallout 76.
I talked about this before.
But I recently watched.
Fallout.
The show.
I honestly really like it.
But I am.
To be fair.
I am more so like.
I haven't actually played any of the games.
I watched my dad play Fallout 4.
But I never actually played the games myself.
But I did do.
I did do a deep dive.
Of the Fallout lore in the wikis.
Where like you look at one thing.
And then you go through so many other things.
Within the Fallout lore.
Because you want to look at the vaults.
And then you look at everything else.
Also by the way.
Let me know if the sound is okay.
Because I don't know if the sound guy is here.
So today is one of those rare days that I let the chat.
Figure out if the sound is okay.
Because I don't know if any of my mods are awake today.
Okay I am going to make the volume a little higher.
Okay so it's like the.
So.
The reason why.
It's a little low.
Okay I will boost it up a little.
This vault.
76.
Oh shit sound guy.
You are here.
I didn't know you were here.
Or not.
I checked if you were online on discord.
But you weren't.
But now you are on your phone.
Okay sound guy let me know.
Oh my god.
JK.
We don't care about your opinion on sound now chat.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Democracy is dead now.
Not just walls.
Not just buildings.
But hearts.
I actually want to know the lore of the key.
Vault 76.
As we stand here today.
We pray that the world will know peace.
But if that is not our destiny.
War must come.
He said the thing.
We stand together knowing.
That here in vault 76.
Our future.
Is not going to be the same.
Alright.
So for those who like did not pay attention to the lore.
Honestly the only reason why I know about vault 76.
Because I read the wiki.
Ha ha ha ha.
When I went through the deep dive of like vault lore.
But we.
Our mission.
Our social experiment.
In vault 76.
Is to basically like leave.
Leave the vault at 2076.
And then like try.
I think it's 2076.
And then like try to leave the vault.
No not 2076.
Our vault is 76.
And we leave the vault at an X amount of time.
Until.
And we are going up to surface world.
To make it a better place.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Fallout 76.
Vault 76.
Okay.
I was going to say.
Vault 76 did not sound right.
Ha ha ha ha.
I mean 2076.
Did not sound right.
2276.
Or is it 276.
The year 2276.
We leave the vault.
To save the surface world.
That is literally the whole plot.
And the reason why.
Okay.
The reason why.
I picked.
Fallout 76.
Um.
For.
To play this game.
After watching Fallout.
And not Fallout 3.
Or Fallout 4.
Is because.
Guys I know a lot of people were like.
Why are you starting with Fallout 76.
As your first Fallout game.
Like what the fuck is wrong with you.
Look.
I have a.
I have a perfectly good reason.
Because.
Look.
Guys.
The reason why.
Fallout 76.
Is my first go to game.
Is because.
If it's shit.
I can stop after one stream.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
It is a.
Good one off stream.
And also.
Fallout 4.
Is a very long game.
Ha ha ha.
Same with New Vegas.
Fallout 4.
And New Vegas.
Are very long games.
And I know Fallout 4.
Is incredibly long.
Because I watched my dad.
Play Fallout 4.
For two years.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
He.
He played Fallout 4.
Every fucking day.
For two.
Whole years.
And I was like.
Oh no.
I don't know.
Ha ha ha.
I don't know if I want to go.
Go through with that commitment chat.
I don't know.
If I want to go through.
With that commitment.
Of Fallout 4.
Every day.
Wake up.
I see my dad playing Fallout 4.
All the way.
To.
To the night.
Repeat.
Whenever he has chance to play it.
He will be on Fallout 4.
And then he will make multiple characters.
And like.
Do multiple scenarios.
And then he will always be on Fallout 4.
He is not on Fallout 4 anymore.
After like.
I think after three years.
Three to four years.
He stopped playing Fallout 4.
Because he.
Started playing other games.
But like.
That is why.
We are on Fallout 76.
Because I don't think I have.
I don't think I can commit to that.
That is why.
We are starting with Fallout 76.
I also heard.
Praise be to Todd Howard.
But like.
Basically.
Apparently.
Fallout 76.
Did improve.
I think it is the worst part.
Because Fallout 76 started a country roads thing.
And then the game ended up being like.
Fucking garbage.
But it gave us country roads.
Anyway.
Apparently.
The game actually is a lot better now.
Similar to like.
Similar to like how.
Cyberpunk.
And what was it.
No man's land.
No man's sky.
I don't remember.
I never played that game.
No man something.
Sky, land, ocean.
It is one of them.
Apparently it improved.
So.
It didn't even have NPC.
Oh my gosh.
You guys just didn't understand Todd's vision.
You guys were just not smart enough.
Or high enough IQ.
To like grasp his vision.
When it comes to like Fallout.
But apparently it improved.
So like.
We get to see if it did improve.
We get to see if it did actually improve.
Guys.
And like.
Because a lot of new players are joining Fallout 76.
There's a lot of like veteran players.
That are coming in to the set.
Like coming in to help out the newer babies.
So maybe I'll have like.
Maybe.
Maybe I'll get like boosted in Fallout 76.
You know.
Guys.
I am not afraid.
To get.
Carried in Fallout 76.
Okay.
If any.
If any of the gamers out there.
With the power armor.
Would like to be my bodyguard.
And escort me.
Like okay.
I need to be like a beautiful woman.
Okay.
Look.
It's gonna work guys.
It's like how like in World of Warcraft.
There's like a lot of players in World of Warcraft.
And then they'll.
So they can get like free stuff.
We gotta be beautiful.
The most beautiful.
Vault dweller.
In the surface world.
We gotta protect the queen.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Sculpt.
Wait I can sculpt it?
Guys.
I can sculpt the face.
What the fuck.
What do you mean?
I can sculpt the face.
Okay.
I did.
I clicked on the face.
Oh my god.
A rare ginger.
Okay.
Redheads.
No!
Oh.
That's how you do it.
Okay.
Alright.
I got it.
Oh my god.
This is like so complicated.
Wait.
What the fuck.
Why is this such a.
This is so complicated.
What the fuck.
Okay.
I'm just gonna go default.
Fuck this.
Okay.
Wait.
Colors.
What the fuck did I click?
It's like World of Warcraft back then.
Where players would be like female players.
So that like.
They would think that they're female.
So they would be like.
My lady.
Do you want me to like.
Do you want me to give you some gold?
My lady.
And then like.
You know.
I am a lady.
So like.
It's more ethical.
The original catfishing back then.
It's like old school runescape.
Okay.
It's more.
It's more ethical cause I'm a lady too.
But like.
The female nobile.
People.
People still.
Do that now.
I gotta be.
Oh my god.
Redheads.
Okay.
Cause they're rare.
And the surface people will be like.
Oh my god.
I haven't seen a redhead.
In a hundred years.
What a rare breed.
Okay.
This is good.
I'm sorry.
I apologize to all the redheads in chat.
But I bet you in 200 years.
Isn't that true though?
I heard that like.
Redheads and gingers are actually dying out.
Cause it's a recessive gene.
So like.
Red hair slash gingers.
Is actually like slowly being.
Like.
The traits are slowly being bred out.
Because it's a recessive gene.
So like.
In 200 years.
It's gonna be even rarer.
It's gonna be like a shiny pokemon.
Yeah.
It's gonna.
You guys are actually going to this.
You're endangered right now.
You're endangered species.
At the moment.
So like.
This is justified.
We gotta keep the bloodline.
We gotta.
Going.
Uh.
Wow.
Shiny ginger.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
What other makeup.
Damage makeup.
Okay.
Blush one.
Blush.
Okay.
We need.
Oh.
Wait.
No.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
You are not having any blemishes.
You are.
Okay.
Actually.
Wait.
Uh.
No.
Blush.
Okay.
We gotta look like we're alive.
So I think one is.
The best.
Wait.
I wanted one.
Yeah.
What?
Give me one.
I want this so I look alive.
Oh my god.
What?
Give me one.
I wanna look alive.
For the surface people.
I wanna.
Oh.
I need to be.
Okay.
Look.
Like.
Not gonna lie.
But like.
These controls fucking suck.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
Makeup is definitely a rarity.
Up on the surface world.
So like.
I need them to know.
That I got it.
Oh.
Yes.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um.
Nice.
Okay.
What's body?
Alright.
Thin.
Muscular.
Okay.
In 200 years.
The muscular you are.
The more attractive it is now.
Okay guys.
You won't understand.
Because it's not.
It's still 2023.
But in 2223.
Muscle is where it's at.
Okay.
The guys out there.
Not only do they like.
Are they like.
Oh a redhead.
They're like.
Oh my god.
She can lift.
Sorry.
Time is non-existent for me.
2020.
2076.
24.
2276.
Oh my god.
Numbers don't work anymore right now.
My brain.
But like.
Being muscular.
Is an attractive trait right now in the surface world.
You won't understand.
Because you're not in that era.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm done.
This is it.
This is good.
Name your character.
Real female.
There you go.
Alright.
Okay.
Guys.
It's gonna work.
Real female.
Doki.
Oh my god.
That's me.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait.
What?
What happened to me?
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Reset.
I can't zoom.
I don't know how.
No.
Okay.
Escape.
T.
No.
I didn't get to take a...
Oh my god.
I didn't even get to take a picture.
Of my real female.
Doki.
I didn't even get to take a picture.
NOOOOOO.
I was gonna take such a good picture.
I don't understand.
Where is the option?
Oh there it is.
Oh thank God.
Okay.
We gotta.
The mouse is like way too high.
Like oh my god.
Okay.
Let's find.
General subtitles on please.
And then... we need to figure out... where the fuck is the sentence?
Game?
Oh there you go.
Look sensitivity.
Okay we gotta get that shit low.
That shit is way too high right now.
Oh this is optimal set.
This is an optimal option page.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I think they look like they're the similar.
At least they're similar.
I think.
Depth of view zero?
Okay.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Oh no it should be field of view.
Okay no.
Depth of view has to be zero.
Okay.
And then... that's almost zero.
And then I'll wait for it.
I'll raise the current FOV to 85.
Okay.
85 seems to work.
Alright here we go.
I couldn't read properly at one point.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay how do I move?
How do I...
Why is my hands like this?
Oh my... oh okay dude it's from my fist.
Guys.
Oh.
Why is it...
Is it...
It's not WASD?
Is it not?
W... S... Yeah it is!
Why is it so difficult?
Why?
Why is it so difficult to move?
Why am I running in place?
Oh.
Okay I got it.
I got it.
Guys.
I'm figuring it out.
Okay it's working.
Alright.
There we go.
We figured it out guys.
Alright we're figuring it out guys.
Oh my god.
It just works.
Is my frames uncapped?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay guys.
We're slowly figuring this out.
How do I... Okay.
There we go.
Preset.
There is nothing that tells me that I can cap my frames.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
We have a problem.
We might have a little problem.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay.
Uh.
I just had to...
Okay.
We might... We might have a little problem.
Time to go into my documents.
My games.
Alright.
16x the details.
I don't even know what words you're talking about right now to me.
I can't tell what you're trying to say.
Okay.
But don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
Everything will be fine guys.
Do not worry.
We'll be okay.
Everything will be okay.
The texture... whatever.
I'll try... I'll try detail for texture.
That should be...
16x the details.
What does that mean?
You don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh hey.
There's the TV.
Oh.
This is my vault.
Oh my god.
I have awards?
What are my awards?
Animal Halloween costume contest?
Guys.
You don't understand.
I have the outstanding achievement award.
At Vault-Tec.
You don't understand.
Guys.
I'm practically perfect.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
There's my Pip-Boy.
Alright.
Nice.
16x the details award.
Look.
There's my Pip-Boy.
Alright.
Tab to open.
Reclamation day.
It's Reclamation Day.
Those surface dwellers will not know what hit them.
Alright.
I'm perfectly healthy.
It seems like...
Guys.
It seems like Reclamation Day came and passed months ago.
But now it's time for me to leave the vault and rebuild America.
It's my turn to reshape the world in my image.
What?
Will you live in a Doki world?
How do I change my POV?
Should I play it?
Yeah.
I should play in first person.
What I mean?
I'm gonna fucking turn down the sense just a little bit more.
It still feels...
I'm doing my part.
Oh.
There it is.
I am proud of you.
Okay.
I'm gonna play in third person just to like...
Ooh.
God.
I'm...
Okay.
It's not flat, guys.
You see that little bump?
There's something there.
That's hot in 2276, guys.
You don't understand.
Because back... back when in the future, it's harder to get good butts.
So like even a little bump is like... is like a good thing, guys.
Okay?
Flat butts became meta.
Alright, guys?
So like...
Anyway.
Anybody that even has like a good butt like mine, you see like right here?
Right here.
That little bump there?
That's rare.
That's so rare.
Hello.
Cosworth!
At last.
Today is your reclamation day.
I bet you're just bursting your bolts to get out there and...
Of course!
I will reshape the world in my image!
I'm re...
Do we know anything about the world outside?
Nothing at all.
The exterior sensors were taken out of commission after that unfortunate business with the nuclear bombs.
Am I the first?
Having been gone so long, I cannot begin to speculate how they've transformed Appalachia already.
What about the Overseer?
That one was not likely to get one.
It's been months.
Besides, she left this place behind to reclaim America.
It's past time to follow her example.
Wait, am I the last one?
Where's everybody else?
I was the last one to go?
Excellent.
Adventure...
Everybody left me?
Opportunity awaits you, folks.
What the fuck was I scared about?
The Kiosks have valuable information to help you thrive out there.
Oh, okay.
Get cracking!
Don't worry, I got this.
I got this, Crutchley.
I got abandoned!
How could they abandon me with my fucking nice ass and, like, rare ginger red head?
Okay, voice.
The thing is...
The thing is, Sound Guy, I don't know if this voice is, like, considered voice chat voice or, like...
Alright, fuck it.
Is it?
I can't tell.
I think so.
Alright.
We're gonna risk it.
Here we go.
I'm so ready for the outside world.
It took me years.
I had so much trauma and that's why I was stuck in this vault for so long.
But this is it.
This is gonna be different.
Being alone in isolation for so many years has made me worthy of going outside.
Oh, I should take some Red Axe and purify water.
Yeah.
Consume drinks to fill your...
No, there's thirst meter.
Open your pit bull...
Boy, I keep saying pit...
I keep saying pit bull.
Pit boy.
And your thirst meter drains over time.
Okay, armor, food, apparel...
Wait, where's my water?
I only have Red Axe.
Where's my water?
Did you take my water?
Or did I just drink it already?
Oh boy, I sure do love the survival mechanics.
Don't worry.
They're gonna see real female Doki and I am going to get so much water.
Okay, we need a...
Radaway and Simpax.
Did I drink it?
No!
Always stay stocked with pedicels.
And don't forget to use them.
I can't believe I drank it.
I can't fucking believe it.
Wait, what's this?
It must be terrifying leaving this warm, secure vault for a hostile to the wilderness.
Building supplies.
With no running warplanes or electricity.
Wait, why would I leave then?
Why can't I stay here forever with all of you guys, my robot friends?
It's okay.
It's okay if I want to be in isolation.
You know?
It's okay if I never want to leave the nest.
What's this?
Join a team.
Open emote G.
Open...
Ooh!
G.
Yeah!
It's okay.
I'll just keep sending all the people this emote.
Okay.
I know.
I understand.
All right.
If you're a dragoon, you guys have to come up to me and use this emote.
And then I'll be like, yeah.
All right.
This is a dragoon emote.
Okay, guys?
This one right here is the dragoon emote.
Just so you guys know.
And you guys can see it.
I just didn't know that.
What's this?
You do remember the whole point of Reclamation Day?
Reclaiming Appalachia?
Never too late.
Okay.
Let's see.
What is this?
Build a camp after you leave and press Z once you're in the wilderness.
Okay.
Is there like any extra items?
Is there anywhere?
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is this?
I know it will be scary out there.
Oh, I can have glasses and a pet?
Get a job.
Thank you for staying with Vault-Tec.
I'm so happy.
Okay.
I gotta...
Okay, guys.
Guys.
We gotta look smart.
Okay?
Where the fuck is it?
Party hat?
Wait.
Where's the...
Oh, there you go.
Party hat.
Okay.
No.
Actually...
That looks a little stupid.
I can't let the surface dwellers know I'm blind.
I can't let them know.
That shows weakness, guys.
We can't let them know that we're blind.
Chat.
It shows weakness.
They'll be like, what the fuck is...
The surface dwellers will be like, we kill off all the people that show blindness so we can be sure that the population is healthy with strong eyes.
They can't afford to...
It's so hard to find glasses, guys, in the surface world.
We don't have machines that make glasses anymore.
They'll see me as weak if I have glasses on.
Oh, this is the overseer mission.
Okay, here we go.
Weakness is a sin!
Okay, Vault Tech report.
Terminals can hold press R to reject or...
Oh wait, but I want to read this.
One of nine years after the vault door closes, you are to prepare your citizens to leave Vault 76 and be in the process called reclamation.
Specifics will be decimated automatically as that time approaches.
I'm in the process.
After reclamation day, you are personally ordered to find and secure three nuclear silos codenamed Alpha, Bravo, and Charlie.
If these sites are still nuclear capable, ensure no one except Vault Tech can access our launch nuclear ordinance.
To be cleared, even there are other authorities, whether government or otherwise, they're...
What?
They're what?
I'll never know!
Okay, what's the holotape?
Overseer!
Because whoever is listening to this had the moxie to try to find out where I've gone.
But I'm glad you did.
Truth is, I need your help.
I've been given a task and I've decided to break protocol and tell you what it is.
Because if there's one thing I've learned in these past few years...
She broke protocol!
Look out!
Okay, but like I can't be the only one doing this.
Like I came in here one or two years late.
What the fuck did Fallout 76 come out?
We need subtitles?
Guys, I turn on subtitles.
It is not my fault that...
There were a lot of issues in this game release guys.
If by two plus... 2018?!
If by six years they still have not added subtitles for that... for the fucking tutorial for that part?
It's not my problem.
It's general sub... Did I not turn it on?
I thought I turned general subtitles on.
Okay, let's try.
Let's see.
I swear to god I turned it on chat.
There's no fucking way I didn't turn it on.
There's so many fucking... Okay.
Display.
Subtitles.
Where the fuck is the subtitles?
There you go.
See?!
On, on, on!
I told you guys!
It is not my fault.
I... I told you all!
I had... had it all.
It is not my fault that by... in six years they did not provide you the subtitles.
I did my job.
Okay, we turned down sound effects a little bit.
And then... uh...
Alright, effects.
Okay.
We'll turn on... turn down and then we'll turn up the volume.
There you go.
I hope it's okay now.
Alright.
Sometimes it just works.
Guys, sometimes it just works guys.
You guys just didn't try hard enough.
Okay.
Let's see.
What's this projector?
Oh, this is like Pip-Boy stuff.
Alright, it's time to leave.
You mom possess the skills necessary to accomplish anything.
How does it again?
Guys, I just didn't buy the... what was it?
Fallout... Fallout First or whatever?
Oh, this is where the slim pack.
Okay.
Open the door.
I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready to go out in the surface world.
And... and recolonize the world.
Guys.
Andreas, thank you for the file!
Get the ships back!
Just take it.
Thank you.
This is it.
This is it!
Real female Doki is here!
Au revoir!
I'm ready!
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just letting you know there is a roleplay community for this game.
Oh no.
Okay.
Fresh dweller.
Battle ready.
Dwellers leave the vault at level 20 with a special loadout of their choice.
Does this mean I have to...
pay?
Okay.
Oh no.
Guys, which is better?
Fresh dweller?
Or battle ready?
Fresh dweller leave the vault at level 2 with a perk.
Uh...
of their choice.
They require training before taking on more difficult challenges.
Prepare to jump... Okay.
I'm gonna get fresh dweller.
Alright.
Pick 20?
People say it's more fun to be a fresh dweller.
Okay.
Action dweller inspiration.
Grant 5 bonitino with other vaults.
Start with a slugger perk card.
Plus 20% damage.
Grants 15% action point regeneration.
Gunslinger!
Oh my god.
I could be a support player.
Guys!
If I get adopted by a surface dweller with...
with like a power armor.
I could be like, don't worry sir.
I got you!
Okay.
Alright.
No you...
put gun.
Mercy all over again.
No.
Don't.
Don't be a mercy.
Okay.
We'll go for gunslinger.
Alright.
I wanna...
Wait.
Actually.
What are the perks?
I didn't even look at the actual perks.
Okay.
Agility.
My luck is one.
That sounds like me.
Okay.
Intelligence.
Oh yeah.
Nevermind.
We should definitely not be first aid.
We have like intelligence too.
That doesn't sound right.
That does not sound like me.
Alright.
Gunslinger.
Is only guns.
Yeah!
That's right!
I wanna be a gunslinger.
I just realized.
Remember guns are very rare.
But it's okay.
We'll make it work.
No.
Select help from the...
Oh my god!
What?
Wait.
How did you know out of every one?
Now give me shit.
I'm a real female.
Oh my god.
They got the gamble correct.
How did...
What?
Oh my god!
I'm fucking rich.
Holy shit.
I can't believe they got the RNG.
Wait.
No.
I was too busy looking at it.
Give me, give me.
Oh my god.
We are going to be the first aid.
We are going to be the best pistol in the world.
Wait, did they give it to me?
I couldn't tell.
Okay, wait.
I think they did, right?
I couldn't tell.
I was too busy looking.
Did they... I have it?
Give me more.
Okay, how do I accept it?
How do I...
Oh, is this everything?
I want all your items.
Okay, combat knife.
Alright, here you go.
Everything.
I'll let you keep your glasses.
Don't worry.
I'll let you keep your glasses and your party hat.
You get your glasses and your party hat.
Give me everything else.
Guys, I need all of this!
They have so much!
God, MMOs are so easy.
Okay, how do I click yet?
How do I...
How do I accept all of this?
How is this man gonna survive?
Okay, how do I accept all of this, guys?
You want this?
I'll request this right now.
You don't...
What?
Wait, did I get it?
No, you still have your items!
I worked so hard.
Give me...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I wish there was an easier way.
I wish... I wish there was an easier way to take all of his belongings.
No, they...
They... How could you cancel?
How could you cancel?
It worked so hard.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you would do such a thing.
I literally...
I let you keep your glasses and your party hat and you still cancel on me.
I can't believe you would do such a thing.
At least get rid of...
I let them keep the hat!
And the glasses!
Guys...
Tell him...
Drop your bag!
No, because I want the items that he has on.
Like, I want to take everything he has except for the party hat and the...
Except for the party hat and the glasses.
Okay.
There you go.
It's not okay to cancel.
What?
You bitch!
I went so high pressing space.
Empty your pockets right now.
No, it's not random.
It's not a random because...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, keep going.
Keep going.
Yes, take it all off.
Take everything off except for your glasses and your hat.
No, no.
Keep your glasses and hat on.
That's all I ask.
Keep...
You keep your glasses and hat on.
Reverse.
Sorry, I'm done playing with you.
He has more items.
Oh, my God.
You know he's a gamer because he has a different item on.
He has different clothes on.
Strong and dragon.
Okay.
You're lucky I'm being very generous and, like, I'm only...
I'm being very generous...
I'm only asking for like just a little bit of your stuff.
Just a little...
How am I even?
I... look, they offer... guys, guys, they offer it for a real female Doki.
Okay, guys, it's not my fault.
They... oh my god, he has so many items.
I'm so fucking...
I'm gonna be so... oh my god, I have to keep scrolling.
Okay, what do I do after I requested stuff?
I'm just gonna request random things.
What do I do?
Yeah, it's not robbery if they're willing to give it to me.
Do I just press T?
No!
I want everything.
Okay, oh my god, I want everything.
I'm just... okay.
Press T after.
Okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna like randomly...
Okay, I'm just gonna... oh my god, there's so many things.
I'm just gonna randomly request stuff right now, right here.
And then...
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, he literally gave me his life savings, guys.
Oh my god, 52 radaways?
Oh my god, he gave me his life savings.
And then...
Show all.
Okay, what do I do?
How do I take it?
And then what do I do?
How do I...
How do I take their things?
Alright, I'll give you my glasses.
There you go.
I would like this much...
I would like all this bottle cap for this.
Okay.
There.
Plus that.
Is that good?
Fair trade.
Is this fair?
Is this...
Is this fair, guys?
Is this fair?
What a deal!
Oh my god.
Can she trade at that level?
It's not stealing!
It's so fair!
Guys, this is not stealing!
Except...
Alright.
Oh!
That's how you do it!
Oh my god!
Is that it?
Except...
Oh my god!
Guys!
Oh!
I bought their stuff!
Oh, I get it!
I get it now.
I'll take your pie.
Okay.
And then...
Um...
Okay, they're giving me their rat away.
And then...
How dare you request my antibiotics?
How fucking dare you...
How dare you...
You know...
If you want my antibiotics...
I'm...
Throw your stuff on the ground right now.
Alright.
Guys.
Okay.
Why don't we be a team, guys?
Guys, we're gonna be a team.
Invite to the team.
Invite to team.
Alright.
You guys are gonna protect me.
Level 52 and my level 53.
You guys will protect me, alright?
Oh my god!
I have a group!
Join my team.
Are you in my team?
Alright.
Throw your items on the ground.
Drop the items!
It's just easier.
Wait.
Why aren't you in my group?
Join my group.
Can I only have one person in the group?
Can you only have one person in a group?
Is that true?
I'm sorry.
He's level 53.
Okay.
See you later.
You get four?
Join.
Oh, he left the team!
Oh my god!
I'm sorry.
Why can't he join my team?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Join.
Don't worry, level 3.
After Mr. Elite joins, then we'll be fine.
Join.
You should... why aren't you joining?
He doesn't want to?
Why don't you want to join my team?
We're Team Doki Bird!
Real female!
Alright, you guys can just tag along then.
Alright, guys.
Okay, come with me.
They're done.
I can't believe it.
Bro!
He's just like, I can't believe it.
I got ditched so fast.
I can't believe it.
He's sitting there like, I can't believe it.
He's so done already.
It's okay, guys.
They haven't yet made any untoward advances, but perhaps you could speak to them?
Verify their intentions are civil?
Okay.
He declined my invite!
Have you seen the Overseer?
Well, yes, but it's been some time.
Also, I brought the volume overall sound guy.
But she was a resourceful woman.
I'm sure she's alright.
Alright.
So what's been going on out there?
Recently, it's been exceedingly peaceful.
I maintained my post.
I can't believe it.
Bro's not gonna carry me.
And otherwise reveled in Appalachia's natural splendor.
But very recently, it seems people have come back to Appalachia.
Those two and more to boot.
The non-vault sort, you understand.
The non-vault?
Oh.
I bet you it leads to the non-vault player.
I bet you.
He doesn't seem... he seems like a surface dweller.
Rejecting my invite!
Alright.
I hope you're on my way.
Alright, guys.
Let's go.
I can't believe you rejected my friend request.
Alright.
You know what?
You know who would it?
The person that was there in the very beginning.
They didn't reject my friend request.
How dare you.
How fucking dare you.
Anyway, let's actually play this game.
Oh, donation box!
Oh!
I want a donation.
What's this?
Okay.
I'll need this.
I'll need that.
Guys!
Donate to the poor!
I'm poor.
Who are you?
Are you a surface dweller?
Are you a surface?
Surface-y?
Surf-y?
Is the door still open?
Door's still tight.
No one's getting in.
God damn it.
We got a tip for the world.
Alright, dad.
I'm poor.
So this guy told us that after you gave him the last of our caps.
He's a...
He declined my team invite too!
Which were the big ones.
Our last chance to turn our lousy luck around.
Oh my god!
The level three turned down my team invite!
Wait.
The big one?
What are you talking about?
The thing that brought everyone back.
The treasure.
The treasure?
There's a treasure here?
Well, yeah.
There was this big broadcast, but...
Permission to join you.
I'm super high level trust.
Oh, my boy.
I think you were super trusting.
Thank you.
But...
Those were the last of our caps.
No.
Someone has to know something.
We're just gonna stick it out until we find them.
Wonderful.
What's the treasure?
This is...
This is what happens when we take people for Granadoge.
Me?
Guys!
Is this like...
No!
Is this the one day I learned my lesson?
You won't have a spare weapon would you?
Yeah.
I don't have a weapon.
None at all.
Wait.
What else can you tell...
Oh, I got a machete!
What else can you tell me about the treasure?
There's a consequences of my own action?
We don't know what.
We don't know where.
People is desperate as they are.
What the fuck?
If you're gonna talk, be immersive.
Okay, so what is the world like out there?
Oh my god, you're from Virginia?
Where am I?
What state am I in?
The voices, do you hear the voices?
I mean, Appalachia's dangerous.
Really dangerous.
But it's better than where we've been.
Alright, I better be going.
I found out you're from Virginia.
I have to leave now.
Oh my god!
That seems like enough I can take.
Look at all these kind donations!
Oh my god, everybody!
Everybody's so kind to donate!
The random strangers that donate!
Donated to me!
Thank you!
I have a gun now!
Look, pew pew!
West Virginia!
We're monsters.
Is that a monster?
Shoot!
Shoot him!
Go Mr. Elite!
Go!
Yeah!
Oh, there's our ghouls!
Go!
Go go go!
Oh my god, Jazz!
My army is growing!
Oh no.
Guys, it's okay.
Overcome or what?
Running will drain AP.
What's AP?
Is that AP stamina?
Oh, it's stamina.
I'm a summoner class!
Visit the wayward.
Okay, where do we go?
Okay, we're gonna visit the wayward, guys.
Okay.
How do I pin it?
Place marker.
Right here.
There you go.
Toggle active.
Okay.
Where the fuck is my compass?
I don't know why I'm heading the right way.
Anyway.
My mage.
Go!
My...
It's like Pokemon!
I'm like the Pokemon trainer.
Guys, I don't understand.
MMOs are so easy.
Oh, I see it!
It's the bottom!
I see it!
Sorry, gamers don't look down.
Either.
Oh my god.
The Doki Bird Fallout 76 experience.
Bro is playing Power Up.
Oh my god!
Look at all these things I found!
Oh!
Is this like...
I can have a mask on!
I can have a uniform!
I can have an umbrella hat!
Okay, I'm gonna have like this.
And then I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna have this clothes on.
Because I can.
And then...
There you go.
Guys!
Look!
I'm not gonna have that.
Okay.
Oh my god!
He has a battle armor!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Dude!
Can I be in the battle armor?
Can I...
Can I go inside?
Where did he go?
The power armor!
Holy shit!
He's jumping so high!
Bro, what the fuck?
He's disappeared!
Oh my god!
Bro...
Guys, I caught a level...
Guys, I caught a level 255 Pokemon!
Guys, look at that!
Oh my god!
Guys!
I have so many Pokemans!
Oh my god!
This game is already so good!
Wait, I went the wrong way.
It's like...
No, that's people.
I have to go to the house, right?
She got a Master Ball at the start.
My Pokemans!
I knew being a real female...
Doki was the trick.
I knew it.
They saw the rare red head.
Turn down the music a little bit.
And then...
Alright.
Wait, are they killing that deer in front of me?
I think...
Okay.
Music low a little bit.
Effects a little bit higher.
Okay.
Alright, we should be good, I think.
What did you do?
Was that a deer?
Oh my god!
Okay.
We gotta go this way.
E...
East.
I think that's it.
Yeah.
Alright, guys.
Let's go.
I'm pretty...
The Dokimons.
Hahaha!
Guys!
Where's your house?
Wait, where's level 255?
Where's the level 255 kid?
I wanted that...
Where's your house?
Where did he go?
He left?
Guys, I had to release him like Butterfree.
Guys, we had a...
We had a Butterfree moment there.
And we had to...
We had to release him...
into the wild...
to be with his people.
Hahaha!
No!
Not Butterfree!
Investigate the corpse...
The public team leader?
How does like...
Why is he that special?
Hahaha!
Why is he so special that he actually just shows up?
I like your hat.
Thank you.
I found it.
See him in 20 plus years.
Hahaha!
Look, we had a very emotional moment.
Oh, wait.
I can join this team?
Carry me.
Wait, no.
That's not...
No, not you.
Hahaha!
No!
I can't!
Wall-E, Walnut!
No!
You have to...
No, Doki.
You have to buy things from the Adam store.
I thought Sun is going to die.
I'm going to starve to death.
Thank you for the super chat.
Cheers.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Not Todd's son.
Hahaha!
Why do I need that when...
When I have my Doki Mans to help me?
It's okay.
The Doki Mans will be here.
Guys, I'm like encumbered.
Hahaha!
I like how you guys are like, Doki, just throw away your items.
I'm...
No!
I'm a hoarder!
Hahaha!
Wait, okay.
I need somebody...
My Doki Mans!
Doki Mans!
I need somebody to carry my stuff, okay?
I'm going to drop some stuff and you guys got to carry it for me, alright guys?
Alright.
Uh...
Okay, I'm going to drop...
Okay, wait.
How do I drop?
Uh...
Oh, drop.
Alright, guys.
I need you guys to carry this.
Alright?
Okay, carry...
Okay, Jazz.
Alright, my Doki Mans.
Carry...
I don't know why I have a cannonball.
Hahaha!
Carry the cannonball.
Am I...
Am I supposed to carry this?
Am I still encumbered?
Okay, carry...
Carry my cannonballs, guys.
Why are you guys shooting me?
Oh, this is it!
Guys, I need you guys to carry my cannonball!
It's right here!
Okay.
Is this it?
Oh, is this your house?
Is this our house?
Oh, no.
This is my house.
Is it?
Oh, it is...
No.
Wait.
No, it's not.
Whose house is this?
Is this mine?
Hahaha!
This is mine, right?
Oh, I...
Okay, I need to get rid of...
Wait, okay.
Oh my God!
The Brotherhood office suit?
Oh!
Alright, I can put my stuff down here.
Alright, we're gonna put away...
We're gonna put away this.
Because I feel conflicted.
Hahaha!
When I had that on, I felt it was a bit wrong.
Okay.
We're gonna put this in here.
And...
Oh my God, a fusion core?
What am I going to do with a fusion core?
Um...
Oh my God, there's Salisbury steak!
Oh!
Okay, I'm gonna put this away.
Uh...
And then...
No!
We have so many good items!
We can't store all of them away.
Oh my God.
Okay, we're gonna put away the glasses.
We're gonna put away...
Oh, but this one has a heart, so it's better.
And then...
Hahaha!
We put away the concrete.
Because we definitely don't need the concrete.
Guys, it's good.
Okay, let's see.
Weapons, armor...
Wait, I wanna wear the Brotherhood officer suit.
Ooh, nice.
Okay.
Guys, do I look good?
Guys, oh, cores are for battle.
I don't have a battle.
Is this mine?
Join the public team?
I'll join your team.
Where... who's team did I...
Who's team...
Who are these other random people?
Who the... what the fuck?
Oh my god, I got adopted.
Guys, I got adopted.
My new... my new leader.
Oh my god.
Do you wanna join?
Are you... oh my god, hey.
Are you a dragoon?
What is it?
Oh.
I'll join your team.
Hello.
Oh, a sim pack.
My god.
Guys, look at my po... documents.
What the fuck?
My documents.
That's so stupid.
How did I have like more stuff?
Guys, I need to throw away stuff.
I'm still in Coombered right now.
Give me a sec.
I keep throwing away things and end up getting more.
Like, how is this possible?
Oh!
Mine!
Wait, no.
Not mine?
No!
I put a fusion core in there!
Somebody take my fusion core out!
I'm too low level!
Somebody!
Somebody take my fusion core out!
Oh!
Mine?
Am I?
No.
Mine?
Am I going inside?
I'm just like you guys!
I look so good!
Guys, look at me.
Look at me.
Is my thing...
My...
Can I move in this?
I look so cool, guys.
Oh my god.
I look so fucking cool.
Just like them.
Just the best.
Why is...
Why is it beeping though?
Is it because like I have...
I have no core?
Guys, can someone put a core in me?
Can someone put a fusion core in me?
Oh, is it right here?
Oh!
Nice!
Guys, I'm so cool now.
Oh my god!
I'm so fucking cool.
I can't believe this game would actually be hard.
Holy shit, look, there's cows!
Ah, cow, cow, cow!
Guys!
I can milk the cow?
Oh my god, wait, I gotta milk the cow.
Guys!
You can milk the cows!
Oh my god, the mutant cows!
Why is it- it's cause there's radiation!
Snake!
No, none of this in this world is perfectly okay!
They don't even have fur!
The first thing you say is why does it have two heads?
Why does it not have fur?
Can I shoot it?
Guys, can I kill the cows?
Kill the cows!
Doki Man, kill this one cow!
Yes!
Wait, not all of them!
Guys, not all the cows!
Oh my god, who's Bessie?
Who the fuck is Bessie?
Holy shit.
Guys, don't- guys, I made a mistake, guys!
I made a mistake!
Oh my god, Bessie!
Guys!
Don't kill the cows!
Don't kill the cows, guys!
A private area is- only you and your teammates can be in this interior.
Okay, make important story choices.
Alright, okay, let's actually start the game.
Let's start-
Let's actually play the game.
Whoa!
Lady, I will paint the walls with you if you don't tell me- Whoa!
Honey, you picked the wrong time to get a drink.
What are you- hey!
Who the hell are you?
I'm me!
I'm- I'm real female Doki.
I'm the last thing you're ever- wait, what's going on here first?
None of your damn business!
What's going on is that this one seems to think I know where this big treasure is.
Oh, they're talking about the treasure!
And I'm letting my people out of refuse for fun.
Lady, this is your last warning.
Our crew is getting that treasure.
And I will happily send you both to the great goddamn beyond if you don't start explaining where I can find what's ours!
Are you- suit yourself.
Tell me about this treasure.
Maybe you can work something out.
Treasures are crew's business, not yours.
And unless I start getting answers right now, I'm gonna start shooting people.
You don't wanna do that!
Tell him- just tell him what he knows so we can suit yourself!
Don't worry, I'll make it quick!
I have a gun!
No, no, no!
Oh, wait!
There's more than one person!
It's okay!
Oh, wait!
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
That's fucking right.
You didn't expect me to have a gun also!
I could have been more than enough for one day.
I accidentally shot her, but it's okay.
Well, not exactly the introduction to the wayward island of the forest.
Thank god you don't miss!
I'll say about that, darling.
First round's on me.
Name's Duchess.
There's something I could do for you.
Oh, wait!
There's more than one person!
It's okay!
Oh, so what was that about?
Your guess is as good as mine, sweetheart.
He busted in here saying I needed to turn over the location of some fellow named Crane.
Who I guess I must have served at some point or another.
Since then, a steady stream of miscreants has been making my life irritating.
Not exactly good for a buddin' business.
So anyways, she's starting in blasting.
So, um, looking for the Overseer.
Have you seen her?
Overseer, huh?
So you must be the one.
Yeah, it's me!
I'm the special one!
I haven't seen her, but I have heard her.
My people found the kitchen and I know where the well-understood camp across the valley is.
Thank you, Super Chat!
Thank you!
She's a bit out of date now.
Maybe you're the one she left it for.
Yeah, hmm!
Only me, because I'm special!
We've drifted naturally onto the topic of helping one another.
Maybe there's something you could do for me in return.
What do you want?
And you'll give me the Overseer's statement in exchange for... what exactly?
Just agreeing to lend us a hand in a little... diplomatic intervention.
See?
That boy you put down.
He's not the first of his crew to roll in here.
Oh yeah?
I have my own crew.
Normally, I'd send my people out to clean house.
But my muscles run off, so I don't have the bodies to spare right now.
Don't worry.
I have a lot of money.
You don't have those bodies to spare.
Please.
Alright.
I'll help you.
I don't even need to know what you need help with.
I have the Dokemens.
The Dokemons.
Alright.
So.
The details.
Yeah?
Now.
Each of these boys came in asking after Crane.
I'm thinking we could make that work for us.
How would you grab the attention of a bunch of single minded thugs?
Yeah...
Alright.
Meditation?
Maybe.
That's what my mom did for my birthday party.
Though I guess no one came...
Oh my god, I'm a loser.
You want me to pretend to be Crane?
That's always got people.
My time, just say what you want.
Okay.
You want me to pretend to be...
Oh, I have Intelligence 2+.
I am!
I'm so smart!
My level 255 Wall-E walnut is like I got a Master Ball and I caught a level...
like a level 50 Legendary while I'm like level...
while I just got out of Pallet Town.
I'm smart!
Ooh!
It's got a little system built in that'll make sending out an advertisement...
and getting this gang's attention a snap.
You just need to build it, use the tape it spits out to tell the world you're open for business...
and then convince any punks that show up to tell you where their boss is hiding.
They did teach you all how to build from schematics up in that vault of yours.
Yeah!
They did!
And even if they didn't, don't worry.
Someone must...
Someone in my army knows.
It's called outsourcing.
It's called delegating.
I'm not here to get my hands dirty.
I'm here to delegate.
Alright.
I know how to build structures.
I can do that.
Mike!
Thank you for the gift and shit!
Thank you!
He's a ghoul!
Alright.
I'll talk to him.
Wait.
Am I hungry right now?
I haven't eaten anything yet.
Bonus intelligence.
You need to learn something while you do it.
Okay.
Are you ready to get this show on the road?
Yeah!
Let's do this!
Hot dog.
It would be good to have those dolts off our back at long last.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure I can get rid of them in like one second.
Wait.
Can I like just send my people out to like do it now while I'm in this conversation?
Oh!
Money!
I have money!
What do you have?
Kaz?
What hape- Oh my god!
Can I be that rude?
Rude.
You look like shit.
What happened to you?
Yeah, what happened?
Outside?
What the fuck?
How?
Oh my god!
That's crazy that he survived that.
I don't know what I clicked.
You know what?
And what's that?
I don't know.
Okay.
Try to listen to them.
I'll do the thing.
Okay.
Uh, what's it like being a ghoul?
Oh my god, guys, I got a mixtape.
Yeah, the Pharaoh ones that I killed.
Why some ghouls lose their minds and others don't.
But ever since I turned, there's always this nagging feeling just at the back of my mind that I will have to feast on humans!
Ha ha ha!
Seriously?
Nothing?
Shit.
I thought it was funny.
I thought it was funny!
Can't say I'd recommend it as a lifestyle choice.
Okay.
So what's your job here anyway?
Don't have one.
I'm an independent operator.
When these folks need a hand or got narrowed down into radiation, they come to me.
Not like me though, guys.
I'm a leader.
Reds?
They don't bother me anymore.
In exchange, Dutchess lets me drink.
Doesn't bother me too much about my tab.
Really?
About the best sort of setup a guy in my situation can ever have.
No, not like me!
I'm a leader!
All of these people can take the tapes take off.
It's me and my dokimans!
Okay.
Some other time then.
I'm the CEO.
Alright.
Oh, they gave me a gun too.
And some corn!
Alright, we're gonna have to hunt her for hire.
Alright guys.
It's time to kill.
We need to listen to the overseer's log.
Camp.
How do I listen to that log?
Is it in data?
Listen to the overseer's log.
Radio?
Oh, there!
Ooh!
This isn't a pirate radio.
Alright, let's listen to the music while we're here.
Is it in the items?
Where the fuck is the...
MISC?
Hold up.
Okay.
Overseer's log.
South of Vault 76.
I knew this wasn't going to be the Appalachia I remembered.
But...
Mutated animals?
Haywire bots?
So far.
I mean, there's people right here.
I'm ready to rebuild in the next few days.
What I can confirm is...
What do you mean?
It seems so nice.
Vault-Tec was prepared.
You see this?
The cooking station, the stash box, the work benches, all built with the camp.
You need a home base out there.
The construction and assembly mobile platform is designed to give you one.
Just add resources, planning, and a little elbow grease.
There's no elbow grease.
There's no NPCs before it?
There was no NPCs?
You guys just didn't understand Todd's vision.
That's what people hated the most about MMOs.
There was no NPCs.
I mean, there was too many NPCs.
There was too many NPCs and MMOs.
So Todd knew what we wanted.
It just works.
I need to make sure every resident of 76 has a safe haven they can start from.
Alright.
I always feel like she stopped talking and then she kept going.
Nice.
Okay, let me...
Apparently, there's copyrighted music so I'll go with classical.
There's never any copyrighted classical music.
Alright.
We gotta go kill a camp.
I need to set up a camp.
Oh, I'm level 3 now, guys!
Look!
I don't know how I leveled up but look!
Hello, everybody.
Oh my...
What the fuck is...
Speech!
Hello, everybody.
Level 380?!
Oh my god!
Okay, there's...
I don't have PV.
Okay, I don't have PV.
I'm safe.
Alright.
I'll give a speech, guys.
I'm gonna give a speech, everybody!
Welcome to the team!
Welcome to the Dokimons team, everyone!
I am very happy that...
to have all of you here as my...
Oh my god!
Good job, everybody!
Now it's time to do a mission!
We... There's no I in team!
But everybody remember that I get all...
99% of the credit.
No, you know what?
No!
I get 100% of the credit!
Just like my Oshii Thomas Edison!
Because even... Just remember!
You're all doing this under the name of Doki Bird!
So everything you do has the honor of...
of taking... of having the credit taken by me, Doki Bird!
Because that is an honor!
Okay.
No, we're not...
We don't need to visit the Atomic Shop!
We literally have an army!
Okay.
Where the fuck is he?
Wait, what?
Did my game crash?
What?
What happened?
Oh my god!
That was scary!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Where is he?
Where is the 100 foot higher?
Read the schematics... Oh!
In my inventory!
Okay.
Da da da da da da da da da!
Da da da da da... Guys!
I need to read the schematics!
Guys!
Give me a sec!
Okay.
Aid.
Where the fuck is the schematics?
What is it called?
Oh, notes?
Oh, there it is!
Learn a recipe to craft.
Am I okay?
I'm okay still.
Alright.
Build a weapons work base at your camp.
Guys!
Who has the best house?
Level 847!
Show me your... OOOOOOOOH!
Show me your house!
Show me your house, Lost Bud.
Show house.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Give me...
Show house!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I need to know where you live!
Show us where you live... What the fuck is that?
Alright.
Where do you live?
It has to be close, right?
Alright.
We want to know where you live.
We're gonna crash your place.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
We're gonna see where he lives, guys.
Guys.
He's level 800 47.
Clearly his house is pretty fucking sweet, guys.
We're gonna crash at his place.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Wait!
There's a level 1000?
Holy sh... Okay.
We're gonna go to your house next.
If your house is not as good as the level 1000, guys, I'm in...
Okay, guys.
Documents!
I need you guys to carry my stuff.
I have too many things.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Documents!
Give me a sec!
I need you guys to carry my things!
Where's my backpack?
Okay.
Documents!
I'm gonna throw away a bunch of stuff.
You guys have to carry stuff for me, okay?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna get rid...
I'm gonna get rid of some stuff, okay?
Documents!
And I need you guys to carry this for me.
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
I need you guys to carry all of this for me, okay?
Guys, I have too much stuff.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Somebody...
Somebody be my backpack!
Right now!
Ha ha ha ha!
I have like an actual...
I have like an army of backpacks!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
I have too many guns!
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
I need... I wanna use the...
pipe... this one.
The pipe ball...
What's it?
The pipe ball action pistol.
17...
44?
Okay.
I need somebody to carry these real fast.
And then...
Uh... somebody carry this.
Don't use them!
Guys!
This is mine!
You're my...
You're my backpack!
Guys!
Just remember, you're my backpack!
Okay.
And then... Oh my god!
11x2?
Alright.
We're gonna get that.
And then somebody...
Somebody carry this for me.
And then... Do I... Alright.
I can run now.
Alright, guys.
I'm good.
Alright.
Show me house.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright, guys.
Are you guys... Alright.
Where's this house?
Where's the guy?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I'm okay now.
Alright.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, don't...
Guys!
Don't use my items!
They're my... It's my backpack!
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, I have unlimited backpacks now, guys!
Wait, why is it just my like 10mm... Okay, I need like...
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I need to like, fucking figure out this uh, shortcut thing.
Let's see.
Okay, quick inventory.
Where is the... Oh my god!
I have some mac and cheese.
Here we go.
And then... Oh my god!
Look at this gun.
Guys, don't steal my stuff!
I obtained it legally.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, don't steal my stuff!
I obtained all of this legally, guys!
Don't fucking steal!
Ha ha ha ha!
I wanna see this man's house!
And then like, build next to it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Totally legally!
I'm just taking my dokimons for a walk.
Oh!
I left the music in the background for this game.
Can't believe!
How did...
Did these guys found me?
Or like...
Like, did they just like, kept queuing up until they got me?
Ha ha ha!
On the server?
Okay!
Shoutout to that one...
Shoutout to that one dragoon that found... that was just waiting outside the vault.
They took their chances and it worked.
Ha ha ha ha!
Hey!
Oh my god!
Look at all these... They're creating a pathway for me.
Ha ha ha ha!
Look at this!
Is this your house?
What the fuck is going on?
I got money!
Nice!
Are these bad people?
I like how like...
Ha ha ha ha!
That was supposed to be like... enemies.
I wonder if there's like actual non-dragoons here that are like...
What the fuck?
Ha ha ha ha!
Whoa!
He's a salesman!
Take off that jacket!
Wait, I can't even use it.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Is this your house?
Oh my god!
Did you... Holy shit!
I thought this was...
Oh, oh, hey!
Oh, oh!
This is your house?
You even have like...
I thought this was like part of the game!
Oh my god!
He even has like...
What the fuck?
My best love songs...
Don't kill me!
That's crazy!
Bro, look at this man's crib!
Holy shit!
This guy actually designed...
Bro, he actually lives in the server!
Who are you?
Oh my god!
He actually...
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god!
He actually...
What the fuck is this?
That's actually crazy!
Bro, he actually lives here!
He actually... cause like...
Each server is different, right?
Like, each server is different...
So we actually got into a server!
He has a wife!
Oh my god!
He even has a mess hut!
The difference between surviving and thriving!
We don't talk about that room!
Wait, there's a...
That's like a secret door.
Literally nicer!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
He even has like a...
Collection!
Holy fuck!
Okay...
I'm gonna sit...
Oh my god, he has a basement too!
The post-apocalypse is very kind to him!
What's this?
I went into somebody's vault.
Is this his vault?
What the fuck?!
Bro!
Bro, I'm in his man cave!
Hahaha!
Bro built a fucking man cave!
Because he got a wife!
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
This man has a fucking man cave!
Holy fuck!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
He has an autopsy?!
What the fuck am I doing?!
Hahaha!
Oh I can... I craft drinks on here?!
What?!
He has a whole ca...
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
This is actually crazy!
Oh my god, he has like brains!
A fucking taxidermy area!
Bro this is...
This is some fucking crypt!
Hahaha!
What's this?
Oh my god there's a spa!
What the fuck?!
I can't get in, I'm stuck!
Why am I stuck?
Is it because somebody's already in the spa?
Oh thank god, okay.
Waiting for response from server.
Guys the spa!
Hahaha!
Guys I can't...
The spa broke my cave!
Nooooo!
Guys somebody give me a...
Hahaha!
It says...
Oh thank god, okay I'm okay now.
Okay guys, I'm living the high life.
Guys...
Guys I'm living the high life now.
Hahaha!
I'm sitting outside.
Guys I can't believe all you said!
Fallout 76 was bad!
Look at this!
This man has a fucking spa!
Hahaha!
Todd was right!
Bro this is bigger than your actual house man!
Why do you have a bed outside?
Bro is this for the homies?
Like a sleepover party for the homies?
The hot tub street!
Hahaha!
Bro the man cave is bigger than your actual home!
Where is the gamer room?
Oh my god!
This is actually crazy!
Hahaha!
There are many versions of bugs!
Bro!
Oh shit!
Look at this, this is more power armor!
What the...
As it should be!
Hahaha!
He has the oval room!
Oh my honestly, 10 out of 10!
This is actually a sick crib bro!
This guy has his own vault!
He has his priorities right!
Hahaha!
What a fucking collection!
I think the most impressive thing is that we loaded into a server that has this person's home!
Like we...
Hahaha!
The house is the front!
Oh my god!
Alright!
Where is the level 1000?
Oh my god!
Alright!
Level 1000!
It's time to show your crib!
If it's not as good as that man's...
Then I would be so sad!
Give me some ammo!
Hahaha!
I need a salt rifle ammo!
Alright!
Level 1000!
It's your turn to show us your crib!
It's your turn!
To show us your crib sir!
We're ready!
Hahaha!
This is a house tour!
This is like MTV right now!
In Fallout!
MTV Fallout right now!
Hahaha!
We're pioneering!
MTV doesn't exist in 22...
2070!
What the fuck!
I need some ammo!
Hey you!
Can you give me ammo?
Hahaha!
Give me a salt rifle mate!
I feel like that guy is an actual real player!
Hahaha!
MTV!
We're bringing back MTV Cribs!
Because MTV doesn't exist in 2276!
We can claim it as an original idea!
I think...
I feel like that bad guy is a real player!
I don't think he's a dragoon!
I think he's an actual...
Wait no he is!
He's following us!
Nevermind!
He's a real player that actually needed ammo!
Hahaha!
Lost... Lost vampire!
He's just here for ammo!
Hello!
I have the salt rifle ammo mate!
Hahaha!
He's just here!
See if I got some salt rifle ammo!
Hahaha!
The guy is...
He just wants some ammo bro!
He just wants the ammo!
He just...
He's just here for ammo!
He doesn't know what's going on!
He's following everybody!
He probably just saw the crowd!
Give this man some salt ammo!
Hahaha!
No it's a real player talking!
Alright let's see...
I hope this... Okay...
I expect Mr. Long lost vampire to have an insane crib!
I mean...
All I'm saying is that LostBod...
LostBod...
Fucking showed us a...
A fucking crib!
Like a house and his man cave!
So like...
It's gonna be a little embarrassing if Mr. Level 1412 cannot live up to it!
Hahaha!
Alright...
How far away is your house?
Holy shit!
Did you build your house in the middle of nowhere?
Like...
Are you a hermit sir?
Like no pressure by the way!
No fucking pressure!
Hahaha!
He does have a tall bar to be at the moment!
Please!
Hahaha!
I like how everyone's like...
It's gonna be disappointing Doki!
Gotta temper your expectations right now!
Yeah!
Alright...
Just you wait guys!
I like how Wally is like not even...
With us anymore!
He's all the way up there!
Oh my god!
Look at my...
Dokimons guys!
It truly is...
Hahaha!
Streamer privileges!
I'm gonna make it look so fun!
With me playing this game!
And then you guys are gonna download the game!
And you're gonna like get like fucking beat up by the first level 30 or something!
Hahaha!
It would be like a new Vault Dweller!
And then you're gonna have PvP on!
And some fucking level 30 is just gonna beat you up!
Hahaha!
It's true they do move in herds!
I have a full escort!
Look at my escort!
Guys!
First time seeing so many people outside of the defense!
Sounds about right!
Alright here we go!
Instead of being bullied by the higher level...
They're being bullied by the level 3!
This is the life!
Who are we following?
Hahaha!
We are following a woman!
What the fuck!
Hahaha!
I feel like they're easy!
Give me ammo!
Give me assault rifle ammo!
Hahahah!
Give me ammo!
Give me ammunition!
What the fuck!
Ammunition!
We are so confused right now!
You still just wants ammo bro.
Holy shit is this your home?
You have a fucking mansion?
What is this a gated community?
There's no way.
You can't have this entire thing as your home.
There's no fucking way.
You built your mansion?
You built your house out of golf course?
Is he Bruce Wayne?
Oh it's not is it?
Where did he go?
Where is his house?
Where is your house sir?
Oh my god.
There's too many of us MTV Cribs for real.
Oh no.
Why am I getting hit?
What is this?
Where is your home sir?
How far?
What the fuck is that?
A glowing rat stag.
Is this your home?
Oh my god.
You have a tennis court?
Bro what the fuck?
Is this actually your home sir?
No we have to keep going.
Okay.
We have to keep going.
God damn it.
Where is it?
It's over there.
We traveled so far.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Where is your home?
Is this it?
I swear.
I swear to god.
Is this actually it?
Oh thank god it wasn't.
Okay.
Dude that's gonna be like no way that...
Oh my god.
I was gonna be like holy fuck.
We traveled all the way just to see a bunch of generators.
Oh my god.
Guys I don't think we can make it.
I don't think we're in Kansas anymore.
We traveled so far.
It's home consistent.
Three generators.
Alright.
Is this your home?
Is this it?
Okay not gonna lie.
Bro.
Okay not gonna lie bro.
I think you need a higher interior decorator.
Okay.
That...
Not gonna lie bro.
Okay this isn't what I expected when I first saw a house.
Wait what?
That got locked.
Okay I was gonna say that.
I locked it.
Look.
This is definitely a home.
Best family road trip.
Thank you for the super chat pushing.
Thank you.
It looks like a real home though.
I'll give you that.
I think you got hit up last to help you decorate your home.
Oh my god.
What?
Let's see.
I'll just say...
Question mark.
.
Where's your shelter?
Maybe that's your front.
Where's the shelter?
Do you have a vault?
Do you have a vault sir?
Where is it?
Where's your vault?
Do you not even have a vault?
Oh man I just need some ammo.
Do you not even have a...
Do you not have a vault?
He doesn't even have a vault!
Oh my god.
We're gonna...
Bro this guy keeps asking about his vault.
How do I leave the team?
Wait how do I mute people?
Guys how do I...
How do I mute people?
Bro this guy is still...
What does this have?
Guys, I don't...
Oh there it is!
There's the vault!
I was gonna be like, I can't believe this man...
...doesn't even have a vault.
Escape social.
Oh okay.
Escape...
Social.
Jesus Christ.
Where's my team?
Alright there you go.
How do I...
Oh mute.
Okay there you go.
Mute.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Alright.
Oh, he got kicked out.
What is this?
I feel like we should have saw the level 1000 house first.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, he has like a little cafeteria.
Like for one person.
Goodbye ammo guy.
He has like a cafeteria for one person.
Alright.
Not gonna lie.
I think LostBod won this.
I'm sorry man.
You might be like super high level but like...
LostBod had the better crib.
Not gonna lie.
Don't house shade?
Look.
There was expectations.
There was high expectations.
From LostBod.
That man nearly built a fucking mansion for himself.
With a fucking man cave.
He is optimized.
It's not about the size.
He was busy grinding 600 more levels.
He set the bar way too high.
Alright guys.
Let's actually do the mission.
Okay, where am I?
I'm so far from home.
Where was my main mission?
I ran so far.
Is there fast travel in this game?
Oh, please.
Oh, there is.
Oh my god.
There is.
LostBod's house is my fast travel.
I have a hammer!
What the fuck?
What the fuck.
I'm level four.
How?
Who the fuck just screamed?
I have a...
Where am I?
Who screams?
Holy shit.
What the fuck.
Somebody got injured.
Dude!
Alright.
Alright, we actually have fast travel.
Thank fucking god.
Okay guys, I need to figure out like...
Don't worry.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking strong!
Okay, I need to figure out...
like... where my mission was.
Where was it?
Hey guys, I need to figure out like where to go.
God, my aim is so good.
Holy shit, look at that.
Oh me!
Third person!
You left the dokimons?
The dokimons will eventually find me guys.
Alright, let me... let's see.
Where's my first mission?
Go to White Hunter.
Build a weapons workbench.
Oh yeah, we're gonna build our workbench at...
Bod's place.
That's our new home now.
Where's Bod's house?
Where was it?
I fast traveled to his house.
There you go.
Alright.
I need to build a workers workbench at your camp to scrap items.
Build a... this is my new home now.
Our new home.
Guys, we live here with...
We are their neighbors.
This... we're their neighbors right here.
How do I build it?
Alright.
I'm gonna try and...
Remember how to build a camp.
Alright.
We are Bod's neighbors guys.
We're squatting.
Okay.
How do I build it chat?
Stealing house?
It's not stealing!
It's not stealing guys!
Is it a place for your camp?
I can't place it.
How do I place it?
Use pit... Oh use pit boy and press Z!
Oh there you go!
There you go.
Okay guys.
I need to build right next to this person's house.
I need to... okay right here.
Alright.
I'm your new neighbor.
I'm your new neighbor sir.
Yes.
We set up there.
What?
We cannot?
I can't!
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
How do I become his neighbor?
You need to set a... camp station.
How do I... wait what?
Oh it's too close.
Don't worry Bod!
I'm gonna be your new neighbor!
I just need to... be further away.
Don't worry!
I'm almost there!
Hahahaha.
No!
Why is your radius so far?!
How am I gonna be your neighbor?
I just wanna be your neighbor, sir!
He's got a big house.
Bro!
Where does your radius end?
Okay.
Where does it end?
Bro!
Why is your house fucking huge?
Who also built around here?
Is it because everybody else is also around you?
Am I gonna come over and ask for like sugar when I'm so far?
Bro!
Who lives here?
Somebody stop!
Oh my god, that's not fair!
I'm sorry!
I wanna be his neighbor!
That's not fair!
Everybody else is like your neighbor!
Oh, here!
Here!
Okay.
This is it.
Alright, my new house.
This is my new house, guys.
Alright.
Press V to start building.
Okay.
Or hold... Okay.
Hold V.
Okay.
This is my house now.
Alright.
There you go.
This is it.
Build.
Alright.
Nice!
I did it!
Guys, I did it!
My new home!
Look, I don't even care about what my home looks like.
I can mooch off Bob's house.
That's all that matters!
I can mooch off!
Okay, wait.
Let me...
Okay, Z is C.
Do I have anything else?
I have a platform.
Can I build that?
I guess I'll just build this.
This is my platform where I give my speeches, guys.
Right here.
I'm gonna put... I'm gonna do my speeches right here, guys.
This is...
Oh my god!
There's so many things!
Okay, and then it's gonna have a wall in the back.
How do I put it in the back?
There we go.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Guys, guys.
This is like really difficult, guys.
There we go.
This is where I'm gonna do my speech.
But as a leader.
And then...
Oh my god!
I can have like food.
This is it.
And then there's gonna be food here.
And then...
Oh my god!
I can have a gated community?
Wait, what?
What is this?
A small generator.
Oh!
Wait, I can have a gated community!
Okay.
Okay, no one...
Okay, we gotta have... We gotta make sure there's like gates in the front.
So no... Okay, actually... Nah, I'm too lazy to add a gated community.
It just...
This is my home!
This is my crib.
Alright, let's see.
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Alright, and then this is my shelf, guys.
You guys like it?
I have a shelf right here.
And then...
Oh my god!
And then I also have a table.
Alright, if you guys wanna offer me anything, you put it on my...
On my...
On my leader...
On the leader...
Floor.
Wait, what's this?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I think that's good.
Guys, look.
Look, guys.
This is where I'm gonna give my speeches.
This is the donation table.
The offering table.
If you wanna give me anything...
Oh my god!
What the fuck did I just get?
And Halloween candy?
And a hat?
Holy shit!
Yeah, this is my donation table now.
If you wanna donate anything, you put it on this table.
What did I get just now?
I don't know yet.
I got a confederate hat, a confederate uniform.
What does that look like?
Does it look bad?
Okay, no it doesn't.
Okay.
Nice.
Actually, no, I don't like...
No, it's so dirty.
Alright, what about the hat?
Okay, let's see.
What do I look like?
Oh!
I look sick as hell!
And my hair is out.
Hello.
Hello ladies and boys.
So, she's judging people's homes while being homeless.
Look, look, I might be homeless, but like, I have a cook.
I have a chef.
Okay?
I don't need a home.
I can moosh off other people's homes.
Why waste money on electricity bills when I can have these people to pay for it?
Where I can...
I can just live at their home, guys.
It's just that easy.
Oh hey, the fixer.
You have been insulted?
What is this?
Insult bot sponsored by Robco.
Insult bot is a social experiment.
The insult bot is in three...
Oh, okay.
I just got like AI'd.
Guys, why do I need to... I'm a squa...
I won't say I'm a squatter!
I would say I am a...
I am a roommate.
Okay?
I am your... roommate.
I'm not a squatter!
I'm your roommate!
That's different!
That's so different!
Where is my quest?
Okay.
Expeditions?
Is it?
Uh...
What do I need to... Where is the... Where's my quest?
Uh... Hunter for hire.
Oh, building weapons for the...
Workbench.
Okay.
Load, broadcast, and activate the connection.
Wait, do I not have a worker's workbench?
What does that look like?
Wait, what's a worker's workbench?
No.
Oh wait.
I unlocked it for free.
What did I unlock?
Oh!
I unlocked my vault!
Guys!
Look!
Oh, I can't even put it down.
I was gonna be like...
Oh my god!
For free!
Oh my god.
I was gonna be like... Holy shit!
For free?
Okay, guys.
Where the fuck is my...
Where the fuck is my worker's workbench?
Oh my god.
Guys, I need the worker's workbench to unlock...
Is that my bed?
Guys, please don't judge my bed.
Guys.
This is not my real bed.
Oh wait.
This is a better bed.
Wait.
How do I... scroll down for this?
Okay.
Control... no.
How do I... tap down for...
Oh, there it is.
This is my bed.
This is my crib.
Where the fuck is the workbench?
Is that the workbench?
What is this?
Vendors?
Alright.
No.
Where the fuck is the workbench?
What the fuck?
Guys, I need to build the workbench if I wanna...
Where the fuck is the...
Guys, I can't progress this if I don't have my workbench.
Oh, there you go.
Weapons workbench.
Is that it?
Right?
Okay.
Weapons workbench.
There we go.
That should be it, right?
Yeah.
Completed.
Load broadcast... tape?
Load broadcast tape?
What's the broadcast tape?
Dumb bitches live like this.
What do you mean?
Into a radio tower.
Okay, guys.
We need to find a radio tower.
Alright.
Where is the radio tower?
Oh, shit.
I'm learning!
Guys, I'm learning!
I live on a hill!
My awesome crib.
Alright, guys.
So, here's my crib.
I have my vending machine right here.
This is my podium where people leave their offerings.
If you have any offerings, leave it on this table, guys.
This is where...
Where is this?
Pipe is like...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
That's a lot of stuff.
I'll be fine, right?
With all these things in my inventory.
Don't worry.
Alright, guys.
Guys, I need somebody to be my backpack, guys.
I'm gonna start throw...
Wait, where's my stash?
Do I have stashes here?
Did I... Did I include a stash in my crib?
I don't know.
Guys, I don't...
I don't know if I have a stash.
I don't know if I have a stash here.
Okay, I got a building stash, guys.
I knew I was missing something.
Okay.
Stairs, doors, light, water, resources.
Is it resources?
No.
I can't build anything here.
Oh, I have appliances.
Make a stash box?
Where the fuck...
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I can't affor...
Oh, I can.
I was gonna say I can't afford anything.
Guys, and this is my stash box right here.
Guys, it's right here.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's transfer everything.
Store all...
Oh my god.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna start storing things.
Guys, I have a feeling that I think I have too many items in my inventory.
Just a...
I don't know.
Just a little feeling.
I just feel like maybe...
Maybe I just have too much.
Too many things.
Oh, I have beer!
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna have to like start putting some stuff away.
Holy shit!
I have 90 of this?
Okay, that's a little bit too much.
That is a little bit...
Okay, I don't need any repair stuff.
Because I feel like...
I feel like you guys can just repair stuff for me.
How much inventory space?
258.
Okay, this is an issue.
This is an issue.
This is actually an issue.
I don't need stim packs.
You guys can just heal me later.
I have way too much stuff guys.
I have a hundred and two radaways?
Holy shit!
Bro!
How do I have... guys, okay.
I need like figure out like...
I need to figure out a way to...
Okay Okay, now I know why I'm so... okay guys, I have a fucking mini nuke guys for some fucking...
No!
My ammo!
What ammo was that?
Is it this?
I think it's this.
Yeah, it's the 10...
Is this okay?
Alright, do I still have a lot?
Oh my god.
What can I still get?
What can I get rid of?
There's so many things.
Is it food?
Guys, I think it's food.
Guys.
Guys, I think I just had a lot of food.
Guys!
I realized guys, it was the food.
Okay, we gotta find a radio tower.
Where's the radio tower?
Is that a radio tower?
Owned by wayward load... Oh, there it is.
Okay, we're gonna travel to this guy's house.
I'll pay you.
I have so much money anyway.
This random guy is just gonna have money.
Bro, this random guy that owns this random house is suddenly gonna get to have so many people paying him two bottle caps.
He's gonna... Holy shit, what the fuck?
Bro!
You're so...
You're so ugly!
I like how this random guy is just getting paid two bottle caps by like so many different people.
He's gonna be like, where the fuck did this come from?
Rude!
Oh, he's not?
What is he then?
That dog looks messed up.
That's a messed up looking dog.
Wait, how am I... Oh, it's cause I'm getting radiation.
A little bit of radiation wouldn't hurt anybody.
You know?
Just a little bit.
Can't be that bad.
You can't call bad be ugly.
Alright, it's this way.
Alright.
Guys.
I just want you guys to know my experience playing this game is definitely gonna be very different from your experience.
Just so you guys know.
This will not be the same thing.
You wouldn't...
The peak fallout experience.
Alright.
Woah!
Oh, there's another leader?
Bro, this guy's 728.
Why didn't I join this guy's team?
No way!
Oh shit!
This highway is under the protection of the responders.
Who's he?
The responders are here to keep you safe.
Oh, it's okay.
Okay.
He doesn't hurt me.
He doesn't hurt me, guys.
We're friends.
We're friends, guys.
VIP treatment.
It's my little...
Guys, where are the deathclaws?
Guys, let's fight a deathclaw!
After I do the radio, let's fight a deathclaw.
Oh, who's...
Wait, what is he doing here?
No!
Mr. Farmhand!
You destroyed somebody's farmhand!
This is where I draw the line.
Where the fuck is the radio?
It's this way.
Okay.
I'm always so lost.
The compass is like literally right below me and I'm always so lost.
Mr. Farmhand!
Alright.
Let's load the broadcast.
Let's load it.
I'm too scared of turning PvP on because I feel like the dragoons are gonna turn on me the moment I have PvP on.
I have a feeling.
Let me insert this.
Oh, that's me!
I'm emergency.
Communication.
Can I load it?
Load.
Oh, I load the wrong one.
Sorry.
Wait, it checked.
Wrong one.
Sorry, guys.
You guys weren't supposed to hear me.
I didn't hear that tape.
It was supposed to this one.
Activate.
Yeah!
Okay.
Thank you for using the Presto Radio Connection, buddy.
Yay!
I did it!
I got a return to my cat now.
Alright, guys.
Where's my fast travel?
Where's my house?
Okay, there you go.
Fast travel.
Oh, rename camp.
Real female.
Guys, do you think they'll believe me?
We gotta go back to the camp.
Alright, so wait to see who the sign draws in.
Wait, who's gonna draw it in?
Wait to see who the sign draws in?
What does that mean?
Oh my god, I got tinfoil.
Oh my god!
I got a tinfoil hat.
Untitled poem.
A moonwood mooning road room in...
What is it?
Oh, hey!
Hey there!
You're a treasure hunter!
Welcome to my crib.
Tell you anything about the treasure you found?
Crane found the treasure?
Holy shit.
Where is he?
Uh...
Let's see.
What he tell me about Crane?
He came to Appalachia, not far back, hunting for the same treasure everyone else is.
Last time I saw him, he mentioned something about an abandoned storage facility he'd picked up some details on, but beyond the general, he didn't share.
Now, your turn.
Where is he?
He's right behind you.
Might be I pay the place a visit.
Appreciate the tip.
Not Crane.
Good luck out here.
Alright, yeah!
I got money!
I did it!
Is there anyone else that draws in?
Is it just him?
Alright, we got more intel about the treasure.
Is that it?
Is there anybody else?
Who else is gonna draw in?
Maximum Immersion!
Oh guys, I got tin foil hat!
Let's see.
What's it look like?
Does it look like I'm crazy?
No, I'm perfectly normal.
Everybody else is crazy.
Is that it?
Is that him?
You Crane?
Oh yes!
I was like who the fuck is this guy?
So, rumor is you got information our boss wants.
I do?
You tell me where this treasure is, and he's willing to leave you alone.
Scouts honor.
Okay, I don't think you should piss me off.
Now I wear your scalpa as a hat.
Son of a bitch!
No!
Okay, I have a...
Okay guys.
.
Guys, that was a close match.
Oh my god, that was so close.
I was so scared guys.
Holy shit, that was so close.
I thought I was gonna die.
I...
.
That's funny.
Wait, wait, first person to get up gets a share of the...
Holy... guys!
That was so scary.
I thought... guys, I thought I was fucking gonna die guys.
Oh my god!
That was so close.
.
That was so fucking close guys.
My Tokimons did it again.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go to this guys.
Two calves, that's fine.
That's fine.
Broke out set to the Shadow Realm.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
The immersion in the blue flame door.
.
Hey, are you a real person?
Hey there.
You must be a real person.
Hey.
.
Hey, Ready Fish 56971 Are you a real person?
Hey.
Are you real?
Are you not part of the Tokimons?
Are you?
You must be real.
Oh my god, this is a real player.
Holy shit, it's a real player.
If you are not a real player, If you are not a real player, Give me the, give me the the Doki Bird, the Doki Bird emote.
Oh my god, this is a real player.
A real person in this game.
Oh my god.
.
He must be so confused.
They are just like, what the fuck is going on?
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
No way.
Real?
Okay, I need to figure out where...
That's this way, okay.
The Duchess's home is this way.
The Doki Monster NPC confirmed.
Okay, enter alone.
That's crazy.
There's a person that has no idea what's going on that's in my server.
Troy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Free radical.
I know I'm surrounded, but I'm taking my chances to rob you.
I did it Duchess.
It was so difficult.
I had a little like...
a little delay.
Because we were checking out some cribs.
Was that weird?
I just got sidetracked a little.
That's like they're headquartered at West Virginia Company.
Fantastic.
So that's where their boss will be.
You just need to...
Wait, wait, wait.
West Virginia Lumber?
Yeah, West Virginia.
You misheard them for sure.
And that's of concern.
Why exactly?
Was wandering up that way not too far back.
The lumber company?
That place was overrun with a bunch of those big green bastards.
Mutants.
I've seen those Frankensteins.
If this gang was able to clean those things out of the mill...
Duchess, these guys might be tougher than advertised.
They're gonna be tougher?
You got any recommendations on how you'd proceed?
Well I wouldn't go in guns blazing.
Unless you got some big guns.
Oh, I have some big guns more don't you worry.
...that I'm sure has had to deal with them already.
There was also this, let's say, special scrapper.
Oh, we definitely got some big guns.
Wouldn't be a bad idea to check in with either of them.
Alright.
Tell me about this family.
Yeah.
You'll find them at Anchor Farm if these thugs haven't already run them off.
But if they are still there, well, they probably managed to work something out with them.
Hey, it couldn't hurt to find out what it was.
What?
What about the scrapper?
The family living in the stalls at Tyler County Fairground.
Guy kept claiming you knew the best way to run the mutants out of the mill.
But, listen, I couldn't get him this bill, Hal.
Probably have a better chance he'll share what he learned with someone who still has an entire face.
Oh, he's like racist to ghouls.
Well, that's a good thing.
Cause that's all I've got.
If you haven't already explored up that way, the fastest route back would be via Vault 76 and trekking north from there.
And take care of yourself, alright?
You're doing us a big one here.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Alright, time to kill the gang leader.
Guys, okay, and select any location you previously visited with fast travel.
Alright, guys!
Doki Bons!
We're gonna kill the gang leader!
We're gonna set a world record!
For fastest kill!
Oh my god, I'm level 5.
I'm like power-leveling so hard.
Those family better behavior, they're gonna get erased.
My Doki Bons!
It's time to kill the gang leader!
Where he at?
Alright, search for traces.
Vault.
Travel back to the...
Vault is here.
And then optional.
Speak to the scrapper.
Kill the gang leader.
Okay, tech's house is the closest.
Alright, we're gonna go to tech's house.
I have so...
Oh my god, it's for free too!
Tech!
Thank you!
It's for free!
I don't have to actually pay for your house!
Thank fucking god!
Bro, what the fuck?
Look at this little cottage!
Holy shit!
Look at this cottage!
They have a vault house here.
Oh my god, it's like...
Switch power pilot.
Oh wait, whoops.
It's like they're fucking... it's like...
It's like the... the nuclear bombs never hit.
Oh my god, look how comfy this guy's...
Oh my god, he has a dog!
Look!
It's... what the fuck is a robot dog?
Oh my...
He even has a dog!
That's so cute!
Let's see...
Oh my god, let's break into this man's house.
Where's you... Are you the wife?
Husband?
Oh, I thought I heard someone around here.
Oh my god, he even has like a wife!
Oh my god, this...
We're just breaking into people's homes right now.
Doggo!
Oh, it's like a work in progress!
He has nothing on... Whoa, where do you and your wife sleep though?
Where do you guys sleep?
On the floor?
You live like this?
Whoa, what the fuck?
Murloc steamer?
Is this food?
I don't have the skill for this.
How do I level up?
Oh, level up.
Okay.
Uh...
Team up, work together.
Do you have reach level?
Disable pacifist mode game settings to enable player combat.
Um...
All damage is ignored, please.
Yes!
Oh!
What's this?
Oh, I got...
Christine broke her neck six years ago.
She never looked back.
Hehe.
Oh, I have cards!
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna be more lucky.
Luck is measured.
Oh yeah!
Luck, please.
40% fine extra first aid chems.
Oh!
Yes!
I like that.
Um...
Let's see.
I don't think...
Wait, no.
No, we don't need that.
What about charisma?
Happy camper.
Hunger goes slower when you're on a team with others.
Gain 5%?
Wait, I like that.
Alright.
Nice.
Use two cards to...
Yeah!
Let's create a high-skilled one!
And then...
Maybe intelligence.
No, actually, no.
Not intelligence.
What about endurance?
All drink first.
Your chance to catch a disease from food.
All food satisfies hunger by an additional...
Ooh!
Okay.
Wait, actually, I should get less radiated.
Wait, actually, no.
There's no way my dragoons will feed me, like, radiation.
Um...
Okay, you need to equip them.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna equip this.
We're not gonna equip that.
Root twice as much from harvesting.
Fast now target limbs.
Focus fire.
The weight of all...
Okay, nice.
We need to...
No!
What is this?
A strength, right?
No!
I wanna put this on!
Okay, wait.
We don't need... You know what?
We don't...
No!
Why can't I equip it?
It's level seven!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Alright, guys.
It's time.
We're gonna fucking go and kill the leader.
I'm too weak!
But I buffed so much of my arms!
My arms were so thick!
Why is...
Why am I too weak?
Holy fuck.
Maybe I should have gotten agility.
What the fuck?
I feel like I'm not starving or, like, being thirsty right now.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, I'm gonna go this way.
Guys, we can deal with this gang.
We do not need to travel anywhere.
We are not convincing the gang leader to leave.
It's a bloodbath.
We don't need to convince anybody.
We are not turning off pacifists.
I am...
I do not trust...
Guys, despite, you know, despite having an army of dookiemon's, I 100% do not trust any of them to, like, not stab me in the back.
Right now.
Don't be a coward.
Bro!
They were throwing in nukes!
What the fuck do you mean, don't be a coward?
Come on, shoot them.
I will die so fast!
And you all know it!
Look at this one!
Yes, you guys think I'll be okay, guys?
What?
Who sent the nuke?
Oh!
We gotta go!
I'm trying to leave!
Oh my god, where is it?
Where is that?
No!
Someone did the end!
Where is it?
Oh, we're okay.
We're safe.
They're not nuking us, guys.
We're okay.
Guys, we're okay.
We're safe, guys.
Holy fuck!
Who fucking...
Did they send it?
Can they send nukes?
Oh my god!
Someone did the funniest...
We'll be fine.
We'll be okay.
You can send in nukes?
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe somebody sent in a fucking nuke!
I told you!
This is exactly why I am not turning on PvP!
This is exactly why!
Chat, I told you!
Dude, those poor level ones that just came out of the vault!
They just had to make sure!
This is where they live.
I think.
This is where they live, right?
This is it.
They used to live here.
What the fuck?
Okay, guys.
These people used to live here.
Send another one!
You get an achievement!
Oh my god!
Alright, guys.
Here we go!
I believe in all of you!
Can I get stuck here?
I discovered it.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm here to talk to you.
God delivery.
Lots of it.
...execute this moron.
Alright, guys.
Let's start.
Let's go.
It's time.
Go, Madokibons!
Go!
Is the nuke still there?
Tune into the...
Okay, I need to tune into this radio.
Oh, I can't.
I can't tune it in.
Did I do it?
Where's the leader?
Where's the gang leader?
Right here?
Alright, guys.
It's time.
Guys, it's time.
It's time, guys.
Let's start the mission.
Alright, here we go.
I have to enter solo?
Okay, here we go.
I can do this, guys.
I can do this.
Hello?
I didn't...
I didn't calculate not having...
my Dokimons here.
I did not calculate for this.
Woah!
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
Guys, I didn't calculate for this!
Is that the nuke outside?
Guys, I think that was the...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
Guys, guys, I need a heal.
I need a heal.
Guys, I think that was the nuke outside.
Yeah!
I wanna see!
Guys, I'm gonna go back.
I wanna see the nuke.
What is...
I missed it!
No!
I wanna see!
Where's the nuke?
Guys, I didn't finish the mission but I wanna see the nuke.
Oh, there... Wait, where is it?
Is it gone?
Guys, where's the nuke?
No!
I missed it!
Guys, send another, guys!
But like, don't send it here!
But like... Oh, it's right here!
The bloodstone.
Wait, let's... Wait, actually...
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I wanna check it out.
No!
I missed it!
Is it still going on?
Guys!
That's... Wait, how long is the cooldown?
How long...
How long is the cooldown?
No!
Guys, send another one!
It'll be so funny!
Who the fuck is the gang leader?
I was too busy doing this mission!
Just saying!
I lost the cooldown, guys!
This is important!
Oh, hey!
I can sell that!
Is that it?
Where the fuck is the gang leader?
Oh, it's down here.
Okay.
Oh, you have to go downstairs!
No one's heard from Batter.
Suspect he finally managed to get himself killed.
Better than a long shot anyway.
Always figured it'd take someone coloring with a full box of crayons to find us our prize.
Can we talk?
I almost shot him.
They're running a parade through here now?
You wanna tell me who the hell you are and what you want?
Two hours?!
I want you to leave.
I want you to leave the wayward alone.
And why exactly would I do that?
I don't know.
Um... because you'll be dead.
Sure we will, kiddo.
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
That's fucking right.
You should have listened to me.
I told you.
I told you you'd be dead!
It was that easy.
Leave the gang of men.
They're freeing me.
They should have taken me seriously.
I had a whole crowd of dokimons waiting outside.
That's the one way to do it.
I can't believe it!
Why are you a wind gun?
Exactly.
Leave the wayward alone!
That's fucking right.
Leave it alone!
You wanna see the new changelog?
Okay.
All right.
Later.
We'll end it with seeing the nuke.
There's a boss?
Is the boss still there?
Hello, guys?
I did it, guys!
I did it!
Give me a thumbs up, everybody!
I did it myself, guys!
I wanna crowd of thumbs up!
Yeah!
Applaud me for my good job!
Boost my ego!
Hey man, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, I needed that.
Okay, apparently people are here.
I'm gonna travel there.
Next.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What cooldowns most likely do the players crashing the servers?
Holy shit!
Is this the radiated zone?
Alright guys, I'm here to check it out.
I wanna check out the nukes.
Am I here, right?
Am I heading the right way?
Is this it?
Is this where it...
Oh shit!
Guys, what happens if I get full radiated?
It won't be that bad, right?
Well I can... Am I gonna... Am I gonna...
Am I gonna...
Get something?
Guys, am I gonna grow tumors, guys?
How do I check... How do I...
Okay, I need to get Rad away.
How do I see it?
I need special equipment.
Guys, I'll be okay, right?
Guys, guys...
Oh, I'm gonna be like the Incredible Hulk!
Guys!
Okay guys, I don't have Rad away cause I...
threw it all the way... I didn't throw it all the way...
But like I...
Wait, no, I do!
Oh wait, nice.
I got Rad away.
Nice, I got it.
I'm okay now.
Guys, I'm okay now.
So how do I... go in?
Will I be okay?
I'm level 6!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna risk it.
It'll be fine.
It'll be fine if I like... eat Rad away.
Guys, it won't be fine.
I won't... wait, it's only plus 57.
Oh, it won't be fine!
It won't be...
So radiation!
No!
Guys, it was not fine, guys.
Guys...
It was...
Guys, don't loot me, guys!
Don't loot me!
I had so much items!
Do I have my items?
Do I keep it?
Do I keep my items?
I can't tell if I keep my items.
I do!
I'm okay, guys!
I'm okay!
Hello, dragoons.
I'm okay, guys!
See, I told you!
I'm... I basically became a superhero!
I knew the radiation would make me stronger!
I knew it!
I knew the radiation would make me stronger, guys!
Okay, let's get some Rad away.
Does it go faster?
Let's see... wait, a hazmat...
Wait, a hazmat suit!
Oh my god!
We got no idea how many uranium-k-molts in there.
Whoa, what a brotherhood.
God help us.
Wait, nuclear strike imminent?
Again?
Oh, it's here!
Guys, guys, there's another one!
Guys!
Let's go!
Another nuke!
We gotta go!
Guys!
That's right, we're gonna run over and see it!
Oh my god, where is it?
We gotta go, guys!
We gotta see it!
The blast zone!
Okay, wait.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, we gotta get in the blast zone.
Oh, put on the hazmat.
You're right, we gotta put on the hazmat.
Armor.
Apparel.
No!
I'm not- Guys!
Guys!
Yeah, guys, I don't think we're gonna be putting on a hazmat suit anytime soon.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know, guys.
Oh my god, it's a naked mole rat.
Is he- Okay, he's not good.
He's not a nice naked mole rat.
Just get to level 50.
Okay, we're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it.
Okay, wait, we need a- Okay, I need a chain.
Rat away.
Where the fuck is rat away?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, we gotta get some rat away on.
Am I heading the right way?
Oh my god, this is it!
Alright, guys, we're gonna watch something beautiful!
Alright, here we go.
I dare- I dare one dragoon to go in the blast zone.
I double dare a dragoon to go in there.
You won't lose anything anyway, right?
If you're a- If you are a true dragoon, you will get blasted by the nuclear bomb in front of me.
He's like, thumbs up.
I'm down, bro.
Let's go.
Give me a thumbs up back!
There's a dragoon over there!
Oh my god!
Is that it?
Is that the- Is that it?
Right there?
If I kill him, I'll kill him in the house.
What's that?
Oh my god.
Goodbye, dragoon.
You're a hero.
Oh shit!
Is he dead?
Oh, he's dead.
Oh yeah, he's definitely dead.
There it is!
Bro, I just watched a man die.
Woah!
And then you put your thumb up to see if you're in the bad part of the radiation.
I think I'm in the good part.
It's beautiful, like a sunset.
Look at that.
See, it's not bigger than my thumb right now, so it means like I won't get hurt by the radiation.
Everybody's fine, right?
We're all okay.
You're laughing.
That wasn't so bad.
We're all okay.
See guys?
It wasn't so bad.
The radiation hasn't even hit terminal yet, guys.
See?
You can walk around it.
Wait, wait, it is not bad.
Guys, look.
See?
It's not that bad.
Oh!
Oh, it's getting bad, guys!
It's getting- I just know- Wait, okay.
Guys, I'll- It won't be okay.
They survived.
Someone's in the middle of it.
How did he get in the middle of the radiation?
How did you guys get here?
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh, is this the event?
Wait for the mineshaft robot to clear?
Wait, this is the event.
Right?
Welcome to the underground.
A boss event!
I'm gonna follow the OS man.
He seems like he knows what he's doing.
Hey guys!
I might be level 5, but like, I'm tougher than you think.
Wait for the mineshaft ro- Was it here?
We wait here?
Guys, guys.
It's like, bring your kid to work day.
It's bring your kid to work day right now.
Guys, I might- I might be level 5, but I got moxie, guys.
You're a class- It's okay!
My teammates will be here to help me!
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
By the way, most Fallout IRLs only radioactive for a few weeks.
A small amount of radiation for- A small amount is radioactive for 35 years.
It makes- It gets in your food, your body, things, it's calcium.
Your bones be- Oh, that's so cool!
What has- What has, uh, Sontium 90?
I wanna have radiated bones, but also not in a way where I can get cancer.
Guys, look!
Oh my god!
There's a level 20 here anyway!
We'll be fine!
I'm the Pokemon trainer.
Guys, I'm gonna be the Pokemon trainer.
We're gonna wait for this to clear out.
Death from above.
We completed it!
That's not cool, Doki!
I should get Rado- I should take some Radoid, though.
It's okay, guys!
We have three people with power armor in front of me!
Am I the lowest leveled one- level- level here?
We'll be fine!
We'll be so fine!
I believe in us, guys!
We'll be okay, everybody!
We might be the lowest level here, but like, I believe in my team!
Ooh, I got pickaxe.
I like the, uh...
I should stop picking up items.
I can't help it.
I see loot and I wanna take it.
Oh my god.
I love, like, the- the environment around us, though.
Oh!
Alright.
One more minute, guys!
One more minute!
So- No, there's enough!
We li- we're having to level 1000!
Did he leave?
Did our level 1000 left us?
Bro, he's supposed to carry us!
I can't wait.
I can't wait to take all the- Guys, you'll give me all the loot, right?
And I'll never play this game again.
But, like, I- it's the thought that counts, you know?
This is a rough event.
No!
He's got- What happened to my army of dragoons?!
Where did you all go?!
Where did you- You hurt my vampire's feelings.
Guys, where did he go?!
Abandoned.
We lost soldiers.
Guys!
Let's go!
Front line, guys!
You're at the front line!
Go!
Oh, shit!
Wait, there's fall damage?
Oh, my god!
There's fall damage, guys!
Go!
Oh, what's this?
Oh, oh!
There's damages!
Go, dragoons!
Go!
What is that?
Earl Williams?
Oh, is that the- Guys, I don't think I'm doing any damage, guys.
Help!
You're on fire!
You're in a power suit!
Guys!
Am I helping?
I'm helping, right?
I think I'm- I think I'm helping.
I'm doing my part!
Turn down- You know what?
I'll turn it on.
There's no way- There's no way he's gonna start hitting me the moment I tab into my menu.
What the fuck?
What's going on?
What's that sound?
Why did it get scary?
Guys, protect me.
I'm gonna turn on my- I'm gonna turn on my damage numbers.
I wanna know how much damage I do.
By how- My- Okay.
Let's see.
Damage number.
Guys, I- Please don't let him get near me.
I need to look at my damage numbers.
Show floating markers.
No, that's not it.
What is this?
Show damage numbers.
There we go.
Alright, let's see.
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, he was screaming at us!
Okay.
Guys, I am- Is that one or eleven?
I'm hoping.
Go, go, go, dragons!
You guys got this!
Yeah!
I believe- Yeah!
Oh my God!
We'll be fine.
Did we lose anybody?
Did we lose any dragons?
It's okay, I'm level 840.
Don't worry!
My one damage adds up!
If I keep shooting, it'll add up eventually.
Oh!
Don't worry, I have so much food.
I stocked up on so much food, guys.
Get back there, you cunties.
Guys, I just need to make sure I don't get hit, guys!
Make sure I don't get hit!
Protect the president!
It means you're number one.
Exactly!
Guys, we lost a lot of dragoons.
There's only four of us.
Oh wait, there's more!
There's more!
Wally, Wanda is here!
Okay, I think we lost a lot though.
I'm pretty sure we had more.
I'm pretty sure... I think we actually had more before we...
Guys, I'm hoping... I'm hoping reinforcements have arrived.
Oh, thank god!
Oh, I actually shot the wrong one.
Thank god there's reinforcements.
Holy shit.
No!
Rad crab!
We got you, bro!
Bro, loss is like...
taking everything.
Look at him go!
Holy shit, look at this man go!
I'm gonna throw a grenade, guys.
I wanna throw a grenade.
The one that is yellow is my crit hit.
I know.
I can't believe it.
From one to one!
Holy shit!
I'm level seven!
Boys!
I'm level seven now!
I'm fucking gaming, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm doing twos!
Did you guys see that?
Bro!
I got to twos, man!
I'm getting better!
It's like when I get like super lucky.
It adds up, alright?
It adds up.
It adds up in the end, guys.
Get up!
This is the best weapon I have!
This is literally the best one!
We can't get better!
We actually cannot get better!
This is our weapon!
Is the... wait, is the two-shot suppressed MF?
No!
I got you!
Did I... he gone.
I got you, Wally!
Wait, what the fuck?
You're just hiding.
I thought... alright.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We lost so many.
Oh no.
I swear there used to be more of us.
I swear...
Oh, behind us!
Behind us!
Protect me!
Guys, I'm only level seven!
Protect... No!
I said hundred!
Two hundred twenty-seven six!
Protect me!
I'm the most important one here!
Don't worry!
I got you!
Protect the queen.
Guys, we're losing a lot of men right now.
Don't worry.
It adds up.
It adds up, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm doing my part.
Okay, let's see.
I know I have grenades.
I know I...
Okay, grenades.
Oh, I have a hunting rifle.
Wait, I have more than this.
Guys, instead of one damage, I'm doing four!
Okay, guys.
Honestly though, I think like... it does not matter.
I think at this point, due to like damage per second, this is like the most efficient.
If we look at damage per second, we might as well.
The hunting rifle takes just way too long.
True.
Oh, God.
There's so many minions.
But don't worry.
I'm okay.
I think Doki is...
healing him.
There's no way I'm healing him.
I am contributing, guys.
I'm contributing as best as I could.
Okay.
I am doing my absolute damnedest right now.
Oh, my God!
Imagine like how much I'm gonna level up by the time this is over.
Guys just imagine.
Look I am contribute- oh shit what the fuck.
Okay guys I'm gonna see if I can equip like a- I have to have like a fucking grenade right?
Where's my grenade?
Oh I got sugar bombs.
Is that nades?
I like threw away all my nades to my backpacks.
What the fuck is going on?
What's this?
Oh no that's just heals.
Okay I threw away my- guys I accidentally like threw away my nades.
Look for nukas?
Okay okay I'm gonna try nukas.
Just make sure they don't get near me cause I'm looking for stuff right now.
And nuka, cola, rattlewit.
Oh I actually did throw away all of them!
Why?
I'm so sorry.
Accident!
It's okay I have food though.
I have food though.
Don't worry I'm helping.
I'm helping guys.
Let's do it bye.
Oh shit!
You know what I actually like it in third person more.
I feel like third person you can see it better.
Wait we did it we did it!
We're gonna do it guys!
We did it!
Oh my!
Yoink.
Like, do we all get it together?
Do we each get our own set of items?
Or like, do we share it?
Do we all share it or do we each get our own set of items?
Only 510?!
Oh, we have to escape the mines!
Oh no!
Oh no, I'm still level 8!
Oh, loot is personal.
That's great.
Oh no!
We gotta escape!
Guys, I can't believe...
I can't believe I spent so long with my one damage.
And I just... I just get 800 damage.
Are you... are you fucking kidding me?
No!
Don't let them touch me!
Don't let... I got more damage...
I got more XP from the fucking Wendigos!
That is so messed up.
That is actually...
That is so fucking messed up.
I actually get more...
I was there.
I got more... I got 810 from fucking...
I got 1000 from killing a Wendigo.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I got participated, guys.
Is this it?
Are we outside the mines now?
Are we good to go?
Oh shit.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Are we outside?
I can't tell.
Alright guys.
Good job everybody.
I know.
I did it everybody.
A real challenger!
Oh fuck!
Oh god.
Yes!
Oh, I just...
I just lived...
I just lived in time.
Oh my god.
I'm...
I'm alive.
Holy shit.
I'm fucking... I'm alive.
Oh my god.
I'm level 10!
Item reward!
Yay!
Okay.
I think I ate too much of the rat away.
I was like freaking out.
I was...
I was fucking freaking out just then.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
There's a jetpack?
Wait, there's jetpacks in this game?
Holy shit.
This game is like so complicated.
There's like fucking turrets and everything too.
What's this guy's house like?
What's his house like?
Oh, he locked it.
I can't believe he doesn't want me in it.
I don't understand.
You don't want the Doki Bird tour on his crib?
We did it everybody!
I'm gonna steal your fucking flower.
Oh my god!
I got three star rolling pin?
What did I get?
Wait, alright.
New.
I got the healing slot.
Oh wait, I got...
Oh my god, guys!
Look!
I got a rolling pin now.
Look at that.
Oh my god, wait what's this knuckles?
Oh, that's so fucking...
What hit me?
Oh, I thought I actually got hit.
I was like, did I accidentally turn PVP on?
What happened?
Okay, what else did I get?
Oh my god, look.
Look, I got...
I got a rolling pin.
Look at that.
You get bounty if you pick somebody's lock.
Alright guys, let's break into this man's house.
Guys, this is my final...
Guys.
Somebody break into this man's house.
I request somebody break into this.
Come on guys, it'll be so funny.
No way!
Hey guys...
What the fuck?
Wanted?
Oh, it's his house!
Wait, wait, wait, oh no, he broke in!
Guys!
We got a wanted criminal!
I was like... oh my god, wait, is this like an interrogation?
Oh my god... he is wanted...
Guys!
It's five... it's five bottle caps!
We can actually... oh, we can.
Oh my god, the five bottle caps!
Holy shit!
Man, guys, for five bottle caps!
What makes you special?
Must be... oh, it's like a level 25.
Oh my god, it's like a workbench!
For five bottle caps, man!
That...
Just cause we broke into this man's house, that's actually like crazy.
The betrayal...
Wasted for five bottle caps.
Holy shit!
Five caps well earned!
Nice!
Good job, guys!
Good job, everybody!
We fucking did it!
Five bottle caps is five bottle caps!
I love multiplayer.
This is also why I joined... why I wanted to play multiplayer.
Because like...
Like you... when you play Fallout... when you play like single player games...
You sort of know where it's headed.
But when you play multiplayer games...
You... every... it's an adventure.
It's a new experience.
Alright, everybody!
Back to my place!
Back to my place, everybody!
I need to remember where my house is.
Where's my house?
Oh, it's right here.
Real female.
Alright.
Here we go.
That dragoon dying by herself.
What can you even get for...
Fast travel!
That's what!
What do you mean?
I should start charging people.
Guys, don't come to my house yet.
I'm gonna start charging people to...
To come to my house.
Just like all the other fast travelers.
I'm gonna charge it.
Um...
Change icon.
There you go.
That's when you know it's me.
Wait, no.
Because I'm the law.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Where the fuck's my house?
Is it here?
Oh, it's right here.
Alright.
Hey, everybody.
This is my house.
Wait, what's in my...
Ooh!
What's this?
Plan...
Plan, plan, plan, plan.
Ooh!
Oh my god!
Soul survivor?
Look at all these recipes that I earned!
Oh my god, guys!
Guys, our house is gonna be so much better now!
Guys, okay.
I got some...
I found some new plans.
Guys, I found...
Guys, I found some new stuff, guys!
Okay, how do I...
Alright.
How do I make them?
Oh, I did not unlock it yet?
Okay, we're gonna unlock a...
We're gonna put this on here, though.
Yay!
Alright, guys.
Guys, everybody.
Guys, in front of me, guys!
This is the leader platform!
Everybody, in front of me!
Everybody!
Stand in front!
Your leader requests you to stand in front of me!
Fancy, I know.
Alright, everybody.
As you all know, before I begin my speech, give me the dragon...
Give me...
Sorry.
I'm gonna...
Give me the Doki...
The Doki emote right here.
Sorry, they both start with Ds.
Dragoons!
Give me the...
Give me the Doki emote!
That's right!
The Doki emote!
Nice.
Alright, everybody.
Alright, dragoons.
Dragoons.
I like to say, thank you for the wonderful experience.
Ah...
Thank you for the wonderful experience at Fallout 76.
I had a great time.
I don't think I...
Like, we did much of the actual lore of this game.
I don't think we did much of the lore of this game.
But I still had a great time that I'm honestly inspired to one day play.
Either New Vegas or Fallout 4 in the future.
Because it has been a really fun...
A really fun time, everybody.
Anyway...
To end it off...
I request all of you to turn off PvP right now.
And the final person to live gets to kill me.
Alright?
When I count the...
Okay.
In three...
Two...
One...
I don't know what's going on.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're the losing older.
Holy shit!
Oh, my God!
Holy shit.
There's so many people dying!
Dude.
Oh my god!
It's
changing!
This is so interesting.
Who's still alive?
Who's still... I can't see anything!
Oh my god!
Fuck, I'm just gonna go through this.
Can I have to hold?
This is my new home now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, who's still alive?
Who's still alive?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Guys, I think this is gonna take forever, guys.
So how do I turn off PVP?
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
How do I turn off PVP?
I started another war!
My PC would have... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
He's like, ahhh!
Oh god.
Oh, I can't to level 20?
Hey guys.
JK.
Wait, settings, game... Oh, I can!
Okay, settings.
Alright, while you guys kill each other, let me figure out how to turn on...
Settings...
Game...
Off.
Alright guys.
It's off.
14 damage.
I'm still okay.
Wait, what?
Wait, I can shoot people, but people can't shoot me?
Oh my god!
I fucking inv...
I
fucking knew it!
I knew I was invincible, guys.
I fucking knew it.
I knew nothing can kill me.
I knew the radiation works, guys!
The radiation!
Is it because I'm next to my house?
That must be it.
No, I'm not!
See?
I can live forever!
I knew it.
Nothing can...
Nothing can stop me now.
I knew I could live forever.
JK, guys.
See, look at that.
Look at that.
I told you guys.
I'm...
I can live forever.
It was the rats.
I knew standing in the middle of the radiation zone would help me.
Look at that.
Anyway, guys.
GG's, everybody.
We have another stream in an hour.
A member stream in an hour.
So I am going to...
Wait, double check.
I'll double check.
Don't worry.
You guys can keep trying.
I'll double check.
Yeah, see?
Hahaha!
I'm fine.
I can shoot other people.
Yay!
People are dying around me, but I'm okay.
Just like Todd Howard intended, guys.
Just like Todd Howard wanted.
Wait, what's he doing here?
Why is he...
Why is this guy...
Who is he?
Hahaha!
But can he kill me?
Is he the chosen one?
Are you the...
Oh, he's the chosen one!
He's the chosen one!
Kill him before he kills me!
He's the farmer.
Anyway, GG's, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Bye!
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And you can stay up for me and your member.
Maybe stay up for another hour to watch one of the...
One of the best superhero movies of all time.
The Flash in 2020.
The Flash from 2023.
Alright, guys.
I'll see you guys soon, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!